thank you
hello
bom bomb
bomb bomb
hello
I think we're good to go
haircut
I got a haircut a long time ago
[Music]
John Rando continues folks how we doing
today
good morning good afternoon good evening
how we doing today
what's the challenge ruin roulette
randomizer
at the spin a wheel for every level and
everything in the game is randomized
which hairstyle would match the purple
I mean as long as you have hair you can
do purple hair right
I should probably make a pin thing for
that hold on
uh but we're not doing purple hair until
I get back from my Grandma's in July at
some point
and then I'll do purple hair but I ain't
going to see her
with purple hair
he's like a hundred years old this might
actually be the last time I see her so
we'll see
um okay
what do I want to say
rune
roulette
randomizer
challenge
spin a wheel
for every level
every thing
in the game is randomized
uh
and you need all seven Great runes
to beat the game
smile
okay bang and now I can pin it
amazing
doing good finally cloudy so nice 68
degrees yeah it's nice today too it's
been so
so hot
so hot I missed your last stream but I'm
here now what up blood good to see you
uh yeah if you want to know the
challenge it's at the it's in the pin
message now so as you see how we see how
easy that is
do you guys like the thumbnail today
I went hard on the thumbnail
I went very hard on the thumbnail
I think it's funny
thy fate lieth under my wheel
beat Millennia yesterday congratulations
man
congratulations
okay so we were trying to do this last
time we were doing this there's
placidusacks in stage one in Ronaldo's
room and then stage two is the duo
Valiant gargoyles
ridiculously hard I think we need to do
more damage with these balls
before
we can continue
we have to find the smithing Stone
bellberry number
ew
there's and I I believe it's
probably going to be in a dungeon
somewhere
where have we not gone we went in there
there's one up here this Tunnel right
here I'm curious of and then we need to
go
into these right here as well plus
sainted Heroes grave we need to go there
as well
as well as well as well so let's go
[Music]
let's go here start
yes we fought plaster Deus Ex we can
beat plassy pretty easily if he doesn't
get stuck in a weird spot
um Valiant gargoyles are a problem
they they are an issue
say the least
thumbnail goes hard
hope you're doing well
you too man
you too
we just need upgrades man we really do
that's been kind of our biggest issue
uh it's not in a new place it's just the
camera's in a different spot
also yes I did beat only up yesterday
I did
oh God
took me two and a half hours
oh no do I even have a stone sword key
nope
oh God
okay we're gonna go get those
I I did not get a haircut guys
I'm I'm not wearing a hat
like I always do
that that might be what's throwing you
off
meow
okay
oh my God come on
we need to find a stone sword key now
bro
yo Mythic RJ
thanks for the Elden Lord membership I
appreciate that thank you so much
that's a big one thank you thank you
stay true to my word I don't even
remember what word you gave but I
appreciate it can I just leave that's
all I want right now
is to get out of here
and go to the round table so I can
potentially buy some stone sword keys
please
thank you
holy
congrats man I watched the first attempt
that was pain yeah I got tricked by chat
they lied to me man they did
they told me the pizza was was good and
it wasn't
but we beat it
I might potentially speedrun that game
it's actually really fun to play
[Music]
it's got to be something right oh there
was one right there for 5K
should I go to a mausoleum dude wait do
we even get
the Rune in a randomizer when we do a
mausoleum
really don't know
let's find out
let's use it gives the remembrance okay
cool
very cool
[Music]
foreign
yeah it's uh just over 20 minutes is the
world record
for only up
there we go
is it just one leg with this one or is
it two
thank you
bro
someone beat it in three minutes yeah
that's the unrestricted one
which I think is really boring
it's just like two jumps that launch you
to the top
it's kind of lame
I like uh when it takes a little bit of
skill
hey what up Luke
yeah Distortion is like the speedrunner
get like twelve thousand fifteen
thousand viewers yesterday
okay
we're gonna pop this
and go by
stone sword keys
have you looked on the lore while no I
haven't I'm working fully on uh the
fallen leaves now so I'm not really
looking at uh any lore specifically
right now
forget where it was
I hate this system the Bell bearing
system is so
diffusing
another one I could buy this death you
think I should buy this death route
uh
uh and we can give it to
rank
I think I should
because he could give us something
potentially
hmm
yeah it is a gamble why are these so
expensive
let's buy one more that should be fine
for now
I don't think we can get a spin
yeah we need 56k okay let's go to the
tunnel
this one
before I went M.I.A you had long hair
oh I I got it cut it's so hot here I
didn't want long hair anymore I did that
like I cut my hair like two months ago
I think
[Music]
yeah it's inflation man it's you it's
inflation all over the world is even
cutting into our video games
oh it stays the same I thought it did
fluctuate
in the randomizer
ugh I've never really looked closely at
those things
they're gross
it kind of like got the Reichard arms
sticking out of them
do you guys see the Zoli video yesterday
about why like there's arms sticking out
I want to grab that so bad I shoulda
like arms sticking out of Reichard and
stuff it's kind of cool
what's up YouTube
reskinned pus of a man
pretty much
it is a good observation
I'm happy to see uh Zoli making videos
again
she took a seven month break
what's this
nothing okay wait it is
hello
okay
oh I don't like this tunnel at all
yeah the movement is similar
I wonder if they're uh connected
ew
oh my God
damn that [__] lingers forever huh
I can explain what a snake is related to
fire if the snake was a part of The
Crucible that joins things together as
the flame of frenzy then the snake is
related to Fire and burning the archery
well I don't think the flame of frenzy
and reichardt are related I think they
just do similar things
like Reichard wants to consume
everything
to destroy it and the flame of frenzy
wants to burn everything to destroy it
why there's like lava around a snake
or in the volcano manner that might just
have to do with the fact that he's in a
volcano
you know what I mean
like a literal volcano
I was already here mother trucker
maybe the DLC will give us some more
questions
yep we've been saying that for about a
year now
yeah it's all gluttony
he's a fat little [__] oh God no
one Health
have you guys even fought these dogs
before I avoid them completely
screw that man
I avoid them
he wants to destroy everything
[Music]
I mean he wants to consume everything
yeah
it's his way of destroying it
just like the flame of frenzy wants to
burn everything
same goal different uh way of doing it
oh no is this an amp
okay he's dead
bird
yell it okay
good
don't know where to go in this freaking
cave man
I always get confused here
oh that's not like a okay
you keep walking around buddy
is he preserving them as family he's
consuming them
I think that's also like it's it's he's
also destroying it
like they're clearly not what they were
uh doing beforehand
you know what I mean who we got here oh
my man
what a way to start the day
[Music]
it's Rick
why is he staring away
God there you go
I wanted to fight you proper God
thank you for letting me beat you God
oh [__]
okay that kind of opens up an area for
us dark moon ring
I wish the sword of strain Saint Trina
was better
it's so bad
no exactly he always lets you beat him
guys that's how it works
what an epic showdown okay well let's go
here now
where we beat Melania
and uh we can continue
let's go
your brother died to him
was this his first Souls game
if it's not
you need to make fun of them forever
if it was cut them a little Slack
absolutely okay
okay
now Rick always shows us Mercy
he's very kind
do you think there's possible any good
any good to come out of the forensic
flame ending
I think every ending
has its own good and bad to it but it
depends on your perspective
like if you see the world as just
terrible corrupt which it is in my
opinion I think the world is corrupt in
Elden ring and the real world but let's
stick to the game
um burn it all down [__] it start over
do it again because this ain't working
type of mentality you know
depends on how you think of it or if you
really like it
um then then it would be bad you know
oh
he's gotta fly him
got it
yo why is that so bad
I thought he died in midair
why am I doing no damage
[Music]
what's up benchwarmer
yo
each of them is equally [__] but at
least frenzied flame is the absolute
worst I don't you know depends on your
perspective
let's try the serpent Hunter
because that was just trash
what am I do here
can you poison ancient dragons
why am I doing that
for the Ronnie ending
right I'm Ronnie's ending is very
sophisticated
very complicated and
the flame of frenzy is just like burn it
all down
chaos baby let's go
let's just flew past me
you can okay
let me try this holy weapon again
I don't know if that's good or bad
against our boy here
oh man
couldn't see it
that did not infect him by the way
now I have no FB
okay maybe we don't do this
this Dragon for some reason is just
stacked up on a Tuesday
then you listen I edit It's The End
everything is over
okay
how can you say if the endings are good
or bad when we don't even see what
happens in the endings
I I didn't I said the exact opposite of
that
I don't think this is the one that flies
away
I'm gonna go up here
[Music]
so many items
determination room four
smithing seven
it's got a lot of eights I'm cool with
this
oh flame of the red Mains used to be
broken right
I think they fixed it to where it's not
like overpowered
it could be a great Rune or butterflies
that's exactly right
yeah it doesn't work the same
Ronnie
hello
yeah she's always here even if you go
here if you even hack the game do
nothing with Ronnie's questline and fly
all the way here
she will be here and you can end her
questline
actually kind of cool
like you could spend two minutes in the
game hack it fly all the way there go
through a wall and she will be sitting
here this cutscene will play and you
will get the ending
interesting
it's because there's no way to access it
until you do all of the questline right
so you know they didn't have a reason to
not have her be here all the time
oh yeah it's a different model guys it
you know
it's okay so you guys know this about
games right like they don't like place a
character
over here
and then over here and then over here
Ronnie's in the tower right now
he's like it's how like how video games
work it just depends on where you are
you know
where you've rendered in
the night sky
it is
travel the path like your hat
one soul is
always to see each other
once more
well it's not going to be the sword
we'll see what it is
I've been lame
amazing imagine
we did the entire slime all right uh we
need another tunnel to go in
another tunnel we should go here
uh not there where hey makira how are
you we need to go
oh I can't even respect either so it's
completely useless to me
um why am I not remembering where I
wanted to go I wanted to go into Altis
I wanted to go to this cave
and sainted Hero's grave for sure
Saint Trina's Hideaway what the [__]
yo that real
on the real Melina can still ruin my
life
yeah which waifu in the game are you
picking chat
which waifu or
what do we call them Daddy
[Music]
which one you picking
all right who's your favorite character
let's just go with that instead of
saying waifu
and daddy
yeah see I wanted blind to be an answer
oh no
aim that right at the floor
I have 30 frames right now because this
game is
there's a lot of [__] out here
Ronnie's your ride or die Fair
sick
wow man that hurt
the felly Lou
melanom Melania Moog selin
you know A Game's got good characters
when people have multiple different
favorite characters
you think there would be like a
definitive one
okay it's a demi-human queen
be fine
yeah nepheli's badass
finally doing this oh my God
wow they do not stagger for very long
oh
I just need to heal whatever
oh come on
[Music]
I love getting hit by random [__] come
on
there we go
if you've been watching this playthrough
I have like so many [__] golden seeds
man
oh my God
are we ever gonna do another Perry
hotter playthrough not with you guys
okay I shouldn't say you guys
but
dude
probably the worst streams I've ever had
on YouTube were the Perry hotter streams
because every sorcerer player came out
of the woodwork to mid-max my character
and it was so [__] annoying
it was terrible
you're not
sure
every two minutes man I hated it
we're so close to a spin
might get it here
yeah I might do it on Kick Maybe
uh how have you not collected all the
seeds I think you can go over the seeds
that you can actually use right
like can I even get anymore
I can
I don't even know the max all right we
got one spin available boys
here we go
let's go
I wouldn't mind vigor
no I did not dye my hair yet
decks okay
[Applause]
what's the challenge read the pin
comment
I
okay
that's kind of a whatever
not the best not the worst not
gonna kill us
I don't really want to waste that
I'm gonna get my serpy boy out
oh I know this one
no I don't oh yeah I do I don't like
this one
this one sucks
why is this guy just dead
oh it's a wolf
I'm come
I need you to go into the light Mr Wolf
maybe you'll just [__] off I'm fine with
that too
yeah I mean it's not easy but it's not
hard either this grave
oh come on
they don't even have an animation to
change color because they're not
supposed to be here
come on rat
I mean whatever
I'll move right on
oh come on
they don't have animations they're
supposed to stagger
oh no
no that is terrible
that's really bad
it's supposed to stagger and it makes it
a lot easier
uh
these guys don't
I'm doing leveling all stats at the same
time running it's going terribly
what does that mean leveling all stats
at the same time
so you just put one into everything each
time you level
it seems like you'll end up with a
quality build I guess
what are we gonna do about this this
could be a [__] problem
all right one at a time
I really don't need this hand here right
now
okay open the door
something other than what we're doing
right now
we gotta go
oh this this could be an issue
you save enough rooms to level up each
stat once at a time one at a time
yeah I'm not quite understanding that
challenge but I hope it's fun
[Music]
thinking
and having that sweep might be nice
wouldn't that be hard to distribute 10
levels at a time
oh at least the door stays open like
that's kind of nice
go go go
get the heck out of here brother
oh this is just not good folks
oh come on they can climb ladders
I didn't know Ms could do that
oh it's a [__] bird
that's the worst
okay this guy he stays the same this guy
is the key to opening the door
for the dungeon
catacomb whatever
I have to lead him back to the bear like
is this even possible
oh God
maybe one of these spikes will kill him
oh this is just [__] impossible
come on bear
I have to kill the bear
come on come on come on come on come on
okay
no Alexander
we have life
oh he's walking away yeah yeah yeah
I'm coming
just drink up drink up he's doing some
weird walk thing
I don't like this
would he just run forever there
I am very surprised that went well on
the first attempt
the first time getting up there I guess
like
that was all luck
legitimately
all look
oh come on
hey at least Roar and don't immediately
Stomp
thank you
okay we're gonna have no FP for this so
you
oh
I just want you
good
[Music]
oh God
he has a reach
thank you
[Music]
nice
what do we get
yes dude that's what I needed
yes okay
yes that is exactly what we needed
now I can upgrade my balls
and we'll have such a better time
that was so worth it
where is it
I [__] bro oh it's just here that's
right okay so now we have unlimited
threes and fours let's see everything
that we need
dude we finally got lucky man
the last stream we did of this challenge
was like it felt like the entire time we
were just getting unlucky
gold and we need four threes
and six fours four threes six fours four
threes six fours
four threes six fours
four threes
six fours
we can buy one five that's great
I come into now I can upgrade my balls
it's true
oh my God I um I think I I need to go
change my shorts bro holy [__] let's go
do that fight now
I had so many extras oh my God
oh my God
because I was Finding every smithing
Stone other than what I needed at the
time
oh man
we were held back
so much
now this this might be real different
man
Jake do you guys want me to be more
mature
do you guys want the Jake that you get
in the lore videos or do you want stream
Jake
and the lore videos
it's quite different
Grease
why isn't that ball falling
do you want to be more mature not really
yeah Lord Jake is boring
true
[Music]
all right let's see if this actually has
a significant
impact on the fight
that's way more damage than we were
doing by the way
him in the butthole
wait did he stagger oh my God
dude if I was in the front we could have
one cycled him oh my God
that was a legitimate one cycle
opportunity
I'm dumb
foreign
[Music]
all right
now time for the hard part
I want to know how that didn't hit
oh hi welcome
should I focus on the one
can't see
I actually don't know how to dodge that
attack
to this day
I have no idea
[Music]
this is such a poorly designed boss man
I can't get over it
it's so bad
okay
Bro [__] this fight oh my God
so annoying
probably the worst design fight in the
entire game thoughts
at least plasty's really easy now
but that that fight's still really hard
[Music]
that was close
ulcerated tree spirit's worse yeah
that's also not good
I like the godskins
I have no problem with the godskins
never have
uh this is how I well except maybe the
rolling
the the noble role is dog [__] like it's
bad
that's the straight up not good
like broken not good
I'm assuming I can't poison the
Gargoyles right
they they are poisoned
[__]
guys there's fire there
that reached me huh there we go
okay maybe we can't one cycle him
how did that hit me what
what the hell is he doing
what you doing plassy
cut it out
you can but it's hard okay
nice
what the [__]
foreign
Jesus Christ
man
they were both on Attack Mode
I like the gargoyle fights too just not
this one
what's the challenge about read the pin
comment
is easy
well now he's easy he was really hard
but on determination
is that going to be the difference
I probably could on this weapon though
you're right
yeah demon princess is really good
difficult but fair
this fight
not so much and I would say that uh
godskin Duo
is not very good either
I don't remember Malachi being nerfed at
any point
was he
[Music]
oh I gotta love the camera in here man
it's great
don't fly away God damn it
yeah radon was nerfed
are my headphones on backwards
where'd he go
[__]
that scared me
stop it
no they are not the fight's disgued
what the [__]
oh my God I [__] hate that attack
dude
I like how they're both called Queens of
a full moon
is that a different variation of that
attack really
holy [__]
and I'm dead
I got a double hit
and I'm poisoned
oh come on give me a break
I don't know if a bulbous is worth it
we got one
I don't have a poison bulb this that's
bad
come on
it doesn't do that much damage
dude
the delay man
on that attack is insane
he like holds it behind him for so long
and then throws it at you
foreign
I think it's so dumb that
they allowed
um like missed stuff
like poison and Scarlet rot to do tick
damage before it actually infects you
I don't like that
all the other Souls games that you have
to be infected like fully like get the
full proc for it to affect you
and in this game you can just stand near
it and it'll take down your health
they're immune to all status effects
yeah that's not good
it's not good man
I'd make poison cures if you can I mean
I got infected once it's not that big of
a deal
like clearly we can kill them
we just have to like
not get hit
foreign
like what do you mean
I better get a great Rune out of this
fight man
[Music]
I bet her bro
do not manifest a golden seed
don't do it to me
what's he
[Music]
oh he got stuck outside
he'll he'll spawn right in front of me
in a second
three ritual pots
come on guys
don't Manifest this dude
man if I'm manifesting a great Rune
right now I'm manifesting it in my head
we're totally gonna get it right
let's start
that's how life works man sometimes you
gotta manifest stuff for it to happen
bro I hate that you see that delay
double hit
there it is again
oh
give it to me [__] you
[Music]
come on
risky
Oh I thought he'd smash
let me Smash
foreign
yeah let's go
give me a great room baby
manifested
yes dude
let's go
whoa
yes dude
radon's great Rune found bro
one more to go
I think I did that hitless
maybe
might be wrong on that one
my sweet
yeah we gotta check the chest
oh wait I don't have
books her key
it's a riot
I don't have her keys
we didn't get that many runes from that
did we not even level
no wow all right well we got a great
room that's good
um
yeah we need a discarded Palace key I
have no idea where to get that
um folks
we haven't even gotten to the
mountaintops and we have six great rooms
that has to mean
that it's somewhere in the mountaintops
right
and we checked here
there's that one boss over here
try that
because there's a lot of items out there
I'm not gonna check the spoiler log
unless we absolutely have to
we do know that the rolled Medallion is
at the Haley tree
we do know that we we did check that
um is there any other way to get to the
Haley tree
to to get to the snow fields
you normally get the key after you get
Ronnie's questline done
it's yes we know
thank you
um we're the randomizer though
oh I just went backwards I'm dumb
there was a skip but it needs access to
the mountaintops so can we like
legitimately not go to the mountaintops
because we can't get the rolled
medallion
I mean we need uh who's great roon is
that morgots
that's all we need and then we can beat
the game well no we can't because we
have to light the tree on fire
oh that's right we need to find the
other Haley tree medallion
we have one of them
yeah that would mean we don't have to go
there at all right
like we can just go Haley tree
or that would take us to consecrated
right
bro how do I do this like I'm just gonna
die
[Music]
damn
I never go out here by the way I I don't
even know how to survive this
I ain't gonna cap with you
I see a platform over here
I think
maybe not
I do have flame cleanse me that's a good
call
is that the boss what is that
I think that was a
assassin
here's something
I don't have it equipped right now
though
why okay guys like if you guys want me
to check your lore theories on Discord
the worst thing you can do is DM me to
do so
hey Peter how are you
okay
uh is this gonna be teach
is that would just not be good
boy
um
how do I get her attention
I think this is the boss right
oh oh she sees me
come come yes come come
on over and hang out we're fun
why did I do that
foreign
she at least in the poison
it should be far enough
[Music]
are you kidding
oh trust me guys I'm gonna cheese the
[__] out of her
[Music]
oh come on
like why move now
[Music]
what a move
foreign
she's still not infected
well no
she figured it out
oh
come on
what is this game
thank you
hey
you
shoot that fast
so is this Tish
because of their the animation
[Music]
what the
hell oh
thank you
is at the Moonlight altar
foreign
God help us okay
Philadelphia cheesecake
we're running okay
come on
of course I have no Health left
or blue
but that's timing down something dumb's
gonna happen here guys
I'm just waiting for it
okay we're good
can't be that good
what
what a day oh my God
we got them all
holy [__]
but
it doesn't matter
because we haven't burned the Earth tree
down so we can't go to the final boss
anyway
at least we have them all that's great
but we have to find the other Haley tree
medallion for it to matter
but we have to burn the archery which
means we have to go to the Haley tree
which we know that's where the rolled
Medallion is
is we looked it up because we got stuck
we know the role medallions of the Haley
tree so we have to go there we have to
use the rule that we still have to do
everything
but
man
okay it's good to have all the great
runes at least
we still technically have to do
everything
okay
I think we can do a spin
a singular spin
dude Dex again
bro
we got hella Dex
all right we gotta do everything
we found
one Haley tree medallion
somewhere we already have it right
we do we have the right one we need the
left one
we have the right one need the left one
so
thinking
it could be anywhere on the map I think
which sucks
dick bro
we could check these Graves
we already went there Robert
should we get a hint or no
because then we would actually run
around everywhere until we found it
isn't it normally in the castle of Seoul
yep dude are you like do you not
actually get what a randomizer is
um
no that's what we're debating we I would
rather not do it but we have run around
for days finding nothing before
all right I'll I'll do a poll
inter no hint
all activated
well some people like the challenge Liam
of running around doing everything which
can be kind of boring but I will do it
if that's what y'all want
you don't play Final Fantasy 16 by any
chance I don't think
from what I've seen I am not interested
in it no
man you guys want a hint huh
going 80 toward yeah do the hint
I watched the IGN review kind of meh
what did they rate it
I saw um
it will do the hint
I saw uh
what's his name
oh sorry I'm like this
I saw a fighting Cowboy that it was Game
of the Year
there we go
hold on let me pull all that [__] up
they gave it a nine damn I've never
played Final Fantasy before so
I don't know
I want hint I need to sleep what time is
it for you it's [__] noon dog
or it's like one uh one o'clock
okay
we need the left one right
right
it only gives us a hint
it says it's in the capital outskirts
hit left right
it says Capital outskirts
what does that mean
screen I mean okay
this is the outskirts right
here
yeah maybe it's at the merchant
no
I don't think the force is considered
the capital outskirts is it out here
I think this is considered Altus
I'm not sure
let me check everything
yeah if it says Capital outskirts it
means it's within the wall right here
I believe
yo what up
let's check this bad boy
can I still get the
um
the the doodads
you know what I mean
ow
the uh
Bell bearing Hunters
if I go into night time
do that y'all know what I'm talking
about probably not
you must be blind look at this he
doesn't look at us look at that
and he says is someone there something
else but he stares straight at our dick
interesting
there it is found it
let's go boys work we're cooking today I
love it baby let's go
making some progress
there it is
Eldon Beast fart Hi how are you
hey we've already fought Melania who do
you guys think who do you guys think is
going to be where Loretta usually is and
who do you think is gonna be at the
halig tree where Melania usually is
I do not know
gotta check everything
well actually we're literally just
looking for the rolled Medallion aren't
we
we don't need anything else
which we know is it is at the Halo tree
so we have to go there
which mode did we fight I believe we
fought real Moog
once
did that ant just one shot me
holy [__] that ant killed me
uh we fought radagon where Gold free
usually is
like golden Godfrey
that ain't just one tapped me
we already fought soldier of godric
we did that today actually
unfortunately he was not the final boss
that dog staggered me right into the ant
and
this is hard
lore-wise this Merchant uses it for
something else
uses what
well I also have 19 Vigor and we're
level 98
okay bro
people people chill okay
massive
massive for the program
we think Jake could just run up to the
Halo tree and ignore any other dungeon a
medallion agreed
and I began our travels
it's entirely thanks to you that I'm so
close to home these great snow-laden
lands stretch far to the North and on
the ancient powers
and the liturgical town of ordna Lies
the place to which I must return
I have never heard that dialogue ever
wow
maybe I have
I know she talks more in the
mountaintops but I didn't know she
talked here too
yeah it's a randomizer this is check the
pin comment
and maybe I get to the snow fields too
fast if I go snow fields does she not
talk
no way Lord dude never heard about that
guys I never wanted to be the lore guy
it just kind of happened okay I want you
all to know that
who wanted to be the lore guy Smoketown
and vati video
they do it much better than me
we are just trying to go to the Haley
tree now
it did just kind of happen it did
what lore mystery to
the ultimate question I want answered in
all the lore of this game is why what
was the reason the real reason
why Queen America shattered the Elden
ring
I want to know her real intention as to
why she did it
it's all assumptions right now
holy you are strong
garnish astrology is great too
bro
okay
my mom says hi she's happy you kick the
scab dragon's ass
thank you Lou's mom I appreciate you
you threw a tantrum because Godwin was
brutally murdered and she was betrayed
or something like that you say that like
you know that for a fact when you don't
none of us do we can assume
but we don't know
watch we'll talk her we'll talk to her
in the DLC and she'll go I was bored
world was too easy
any better suggestions I'm yeah there's
tons
I've made multiple videos on it
that reason is one of them
oh God I should not have instigated this
what what I'm saying is we do not have a
definitive answer on why it happened
that's what I'm saying
that is what I would like to know for
sure
yeah that's where you get the um Knights
Cavalry armor set is from those guys
she sneezed and the ring broke
Maybe
I mean
have you guys seen Death Note
one of the very few animes I've watched
but I like death note
you know the reason one of those
um what are they called the demons that
have the death note
or give them out or drop them or lose
them what are they called
I forget they're like demons or whatever
right
she slipped and fell and it broke Maybe
yeah Shinigami
what was the reason that he dropped his
death note in the human Realm
he was bored
I think that's a great reason to do
something like that and and it like made
it so much it gave a vibe to the show
that was like any other show I've
watched It's like holy [__] he was
actually just bored that's that's cool
to me it really is you know
maybe America was bored as hell
maybe who knows
maybe she did this fall over and we
won't know definitively until we meet
her and she tells us or someone tells us
exactly what happened
which we have not gotten yet
we just know that she was driven to the
brink we just don't know in what fashion
or what way or whatever you know what I
mean
it's out my ass bro I fell
sorry I lose mom that was inappropriate
teenage angst I don't think she's a
teenager
she's had many kids
I guess you can have kids when never
mind
it was inside her maybe she just did
fall over
it was Insider
he was the vessel for the Eldon ring
in the show Lucifer Lucifer was bored
with hell so he went to LA to own a
nightclub the
I mean
don't you guys do certain things because
you're bored as well
I have
sir you do an absurd amount of damage
okay
no yes you do
come on
I got blood on my face
I started making content because I was
bored
and it was fun
watch the anime not the live action if
you're gonna watch it books are better
though
I've watched I've watched the whole
anime it's really good
I don't watch very many animes
but um
I like death note a lot
I I think even if you don't like anime
you would like death note
because I'm like legitimately one of
those people that don't really like it
but some of them hit
pretty pretty well and it can be cool
I respect it
there we go
I was born then let's go to
pre-engineering school and I hate math
I mean did you do it to get better at
math
I sometimes poke my dog
when she's asleep to wake her up then
pretend I didn't touch her and she looks
around trying to figure out what touched
her
just causing pure chaos in the world huh
imagine
why do you guys watch streams
why do you guys watch YouTube videos or
content probably because you're bored
trying to be entertained while you're
doing something else
there's lots of reasons to do things out
of [__] boredom man
yo what's up Ukraine how are you all
good here
I think
otakis sometimes forget that anime manga
is just another kind of entertainment
Realm
what's up
otakis
and as with every other media there are
good ones and bad ones
well yeah of course
bro I do not like a dino dog up here
I just want to reason to ban people okay
please don't do that out of boredom
hot ban someone in the Discord
you guys see that
and it wasn't out of boredom
started modding my car out of boredom
and now I I make a living working with
vehicles
yeah maybe Queen America just wanted to
shake things up guys I think that's a
very valid reason to do something
[Music]
personally
foreign
somewhere else buddy
haha you fell idiot
to find a funny chat and I can't
anticipate with
you mean participate
right now I'm working out while
listening to you streams are very
engaging see
I'm bored so I'm gonna attempt to end
the world
wait wasn't that the reason that the
main character in Death Note did it as
well
I don't remember
what's his name
light
didn't didn't he start killing criminals
out of boredom
like wasn't that one of his reasons I
guess
get me out of here
thank you
the show seems super edgy
it's very edgy actually it's extremely
edgy man
but yeah wasn't he so smart that he got
bored with like everything that he was
doing and just decided to
become God essentially
yeah he thought the world was [__] up
yep got it God he got a God complex but
I I swear there was a scene in the show
where he said
a remembrance
um we should go see what this gives us
real quick
wasn't there a scene in the show where
light says that like
doesn't
his demon
is Shinigami ask him why he's doing it
and he says that
he's bored
I don't know
I don't remember
I rewatched it like a couple months ago
and I was like holy [__] this show is so
good it's like actually
death note's one of the best shows I've
ever seen
and I don't even like anime as I said
like not a lot of them
is wait what did she say
we're not abandoning you but we'll be
back in a few thousand years when you're
all dead
thank you
lame okay
I'm gonna take this potato chip and eat
it
that's a line from the show by the way
I'm gonna take this potato chip
and eat it
it's so [__] stupid
but really good at the same time
like that show gets Goofy
from time to time
but it's fun
yo what up Nick main character with
giren login got bored
of working so they decided to go ape
[__] and Achieve insane wonders
hmm
the first half of the first episode
established him as the smartest kid at
school
and that he's so achieved he's now bored
with life yeah and that was like the big
reason that he started doing all this
crazy [__] because he was straight up
bored
and we're getting all the remembrances
oh this spot could be real bad
let's get out of here
I'm gonna take this potato chip
and eat it
skip
[Music]
all right let's go see
wait I didn't look at who was over there
can't see
I always wonder why the English dub of
so many animes are kind of goofy
do you think it's because the dialogue
in most animes are goofy
like just the overall dialogue uh like
imagine working with that line as a as
an English dub actor voice actor
he's probably reading it going he really
says this like he said like like he's
gonna
yell that he's eating a potato chip
[Music]
you know maybe
he nailed it though I'm gonna take this
potato chip
and eat it I think he nailed it
maybe he probably laughed after he did
it exactly
my favorite weapon in the game and I
can't use it
not enough strength not enough ant feels
bad man
I think we can get a spin out of this
though
not enough strength and not enough in
we can do a spinny spin though
one
it's the Box stick baby
all right
sit
[__] you
[Applause]
uh fine
it doesn't even matter anymore
okay
let's continue we're probably gonna have
to kill Melania to get the role of
Medallion or at least wherever Melania
is in here
no we're not doing multi-streaming
anymore
I I had a good conversation with my
YouTube Partner manager and she advised
me that you can do it if you want it's
just not recommended
I had a good conversation with her so it
opened me up to uh
thinking differently on how I do this
like I wasn't even gonna stream on this
main Channel anymore but after talking
with her
she uh he said that I should
foreign
you missed a bunch of items we don't
need them anymore remember well actually
they could all be here
calm down
all right who we got here
oh my God
oh it's Reichard as well
well
this is an interesting spot
together
oh this is not good folks
wait
doesn't this work
it does
I can't see I need more room
joined the serpent King as family
am I even gonna be able to dodge all
these
oh the skulls don't even come out
huge
that makes you a joke
I shouldn't have said anything I'm sorry
oh
this uh camera angle
is crazy
I'm not going to get a staggered
wait that lava doesn't even work
no oh
we're getting lucky
[__] it
there it is baby
there it is
GG
holy [__] we are cooking with gas
and 220 thousand
oh my God
should we continue through here
we don't need to anymore
we can we can just go to the fire giant
light it on fire kill whoever malacath
is and and GG
yeah we're probably going to get Arcane
gas it you know I'm I'm expecting it
at this point
I really am
you know what no our luck has been good
and I'm gonna manifest
um Vigor I'm doing it
I'm manifesting at least one point into
bigger
watch it happen
watch it happen folks
have you killed the other great Roots we
have all of the great roots
we just didn't have to kill every uh
main boss to do so
[Music]
hey I've aligned my aura I need y'all to
do the same all right
no more no more negative [__] in here
okay
positive
let's put on our fake YouTuber voices
and and manifest some positivity in here
all right guys
here we are
at Millicent's Church
with lots of runes in our possession
finally we have three spinny spins let's
see what we can get
I'm really hoping for for some Vigor I'm
gonna manifest it into the world if it
lands on Arcane it's okay
you guys like that voice
all right spin number one folks let's
see what we get
hey one of our weapon scales really well
with faith so that's actually a w spin
that's a huge W spin
[Applause]
poggers in the chat right
I'm gonna keep doing it
okay spin number two
really hoping for some Vigor might not
get it but that's okay we have plenty of
points in the decks we're just making
that a nice rounded number at 30.
that's why I wanted to give it to us now
it's going to make an even better
rounded number with getting us to 20
Vigor let's get it
manifesting in it
[Applause]
and that's why you stay positive folks
that's why you stay positive
and I
I cannot talk like that for more than
five minutes we're good okay
um [__] it we're going to the world
thing let's finish this
oh
you guys know like a lot of YouTubers
fake it to sound like that right
if it lands on Vigor I'm gonna donate
ten thousand dollars to charity
see I said that after it's too late
I'm gonna give ten thousand dollars to
ten thousand different homeless people
make sure to subscribe to Mr Beast
all right
yo what up seventh how are you
you're quarterly check-in
donate your Tesla to charity don't worry
about it my lease ends in April and that
thing is gone
I may not even get a car
I may just not have a car for a while
I don't gotta go nowhere
oh yeah I do
I'll probably get a shitty car
something less expensive
you're not gonna finish the Halo tree
we might go see
we might go check it out yeah I gotta go
to the golf course and that's pretty
much it
ooh what are you
like that
people who talk like that unironically
have gotten their brain randomized
you think so
one of your members is a car salesman
let's go
listen I like my Tesla
um
I do
but that monthly payment man oh my God
I probably wouldn't get a Tesla again
unless I could buy
one straight up
and it would be the nice one Like the
Model S
I wouldn't get a model 3 again
but yeah the you basically need to have
a car in the United States to get
anywhere
you like really do
I'm not gonna tell you my payment it's a
lot
you goofball
well I guess I could
I don't care
that that car is 450 a month bro
for three years and my lease ends in
April
next year
you gonna give me anything
yeah that's a lot
you could refinance the next car you get
well yeah of course
bruh
amazing
uh when I went to Texas for work I
couldn't do anything without an Uber
you you quite literally can't go
anywhere it's crazy
hey there she is
yeah I think I would just next time
next time I would just buy a car and
finance it yeah
or less
and then I could actually sell it
when I'm done with it you know
yeah you really don't want to end up on
the on the sidewalks around here
you'll just be very close
to a uh
death
with other cars
drive it till it quits yeah I I I it's
fine I don't mind it I can afford it
barely but I can't
I I kind of regret the apartment a
little bit Chad because my parents were
like totally fine with me staying with
them
until I made x amount of money or
whatever but
it's okay I wanted to see if I could do
this full time and live on my own and I
can but it's a very it's cutting it
close say the least
but I know oh like renting an apartment
I am not kidding every month
at the beginning of every month guys I
am it's like I'm throwing money into a
fire pit it's crazy
that's what it feels like it like I know
I'm living on my own and that's what I'm
paying for
but oh my God
Jesus
just a lot of money
hey look at that another golden seed
oh I love this place it's great
it's it's the nicest apartment I've ever
had
I think I can level
oh
I did see a video that um
you should get married and buy a house
pretty easy to be honest yeah for you
I keep being with girls that want
nothing to do with me after a couple
years man
all right one level
and now they're all getting married
[__]
because I wasn't positive
didn't put on the YouTuber voice
I didn't do the voice it's why we got a
bad spin
yeah every girl that I've been with long
term I believe is married or getting
married now
so that's great
I hear ranala is single she's [__]
crazy
hahaha
and not real
at least part of the apartment rents can
be a tax write-off
you would think that
it's hard to declare it as a as a
business expense
at least you're not like a guy I knew
that all his exes became lesbian
that would be hard
they usually are my dude
okay so the girl the last relationship I
was in was in 2021 I dated this girl for
a year she was [__] crazy and I found
out recently that she's pregnant and
getting married to a guy that she met
two months ago
I'm fine
with that because she's crazy
but they're probably getting married
because they're gonna have a kid
yeah I dodged a bullet
but that's who I dated
wasted my time
I also dated a girl for six years who
broke up with me because I wasn't
religious
which she knew about for six years
I was never at any point religious
I appreciate that way thank you
all my game crashed
oh there must be something crazy in
there
that's an excuse
to to string me along for six years
yeah that's a great reason to do that
that is what happened Trey
and she did she got engaged last week
I'm very happy for her but
strung me along for six years
knew I wasn't religious and then broke
up with me because I wasn't religious
one to have a nice Christian home with
this no problem with that but holy [__]
would have been nice uh to know that
that was that important to you
uh kind of cobaltia
you guys know uh
one month before she broke up with me
she tried to buy me a Bible
when she came to visit me at college
I gave it a try and I said ah this don't
think it's for me
broke up with me a month later
again nothing wrong with that but she
knew I wasn't religious and dated me
telling me it was fine for years
when it clearly wasn't
all right who we got
what is that oh it's four to sacks right
I think you're right Trey that's fine it
fire four to six that's actually a sick
name
um
that's fine trade it six years of my
life down the drain though
[Music]
oh okay
no no no it it it totally makes sense
for her to want to have a
did I not grab the grace up there
what the [__]
um or her to want to have
that religious upbringing with her
family and her spouse and whatever
that's totally fine
she knew that though
and you know you know what like here
here's what hits the worst with that and
like it's been years guys I'm over it
I'm just talking
the guy she's getting married to was the
guy she would always talk about every
year when she came back from Summer
Church camp
that it's just like yeah I [__] knew
it
I should have known kept going
but whatever
every year she'd go to the summer Church
camp where I didn't get to talk to her
for a month because they weren't allowed
to have a phone or anything and she'd
always come back and talk about this guy
and now she's getting married to him
sucks
happy for her but [__] me for six years
right
on the loafers
what does that mean
you should shatter an Elden ring
[__] it I'll do it
sounds like she did some Unholy things
uh
probably not
she probably had some Unholy thoughts
it's a very old saying for being gay
I I he's he's clearly not he's getting
married to her
[Music]
keep that knee right there baby
oh using Torah he gets four to sacks
kind of neat
[Music]
how what's happening
I'm dead yeah I forgot about his fire
attack
oh a little
it doesn't matter
that's fine
are you dating girls just because you're
bored I'm not dating anybody recently
they always turn out to be [__] crazy
so I I kind of stopped
is radagon America
is America radagon
I think there will be a stage two yeah
so we gotta be four to six first
[Music]
thank you
oh
my God
how did that not hit
[Music]
this is uh not going well
wait how did we get four to sack's theme
with this
it's like really lucky
oh this is class to do sex sorry
kind of similar
where are you going
[Music]
foreign
rarely
um staggers
come on
don't kill me
that's fire yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
no stop
no
this is awful okay we're fine
[Music]
no
Duty punched me back into it
thank God we are out of that spot
whatever whatever
all right who we got
oh
that was a really interesting way to
have that come out
should I use the holy weapon Maybe
[Music]
because she can't bleed
and she could staggered though this is
fine
[Music]
that's what we want
foreign
oh brother
um bruh don't spam that [__] at me
yeah it's pretty good
this music reminds me of little
nightmares
[Music]
little nightmares too
how did those just came up out of
nowhere the [__]
foreign
oh my God the game tried to kill me man
come on God
the game tried it's hardest to [__] me
over man
holy [__]
all right nice
it tried so hard to kill me right there
nice
all right what were we talking about
you're talking about something before
they got serious all right two spins
yo might as well give us more Arcane why
the [__] not
all right guys we're totally gonna get
bigger on this next thing here we go
it's time to get a little bit more
Health to give us just a that little bit
of edge we didn't [__] me all right
thanks fine too
[Applause]
I
I whatever
good enough
okay guys
welcome back to another video
what we're doing today is called roon
roulette
where I have to spin a wheel every time
I have to level up whatever it lands on
that's what I have to put a point into
if you like the challenge make sure to
drop a like
leave a comment on the end of the video
and suck my dick okay
I'm done I'm done I'm done
no
we'll complain only up here
shut up sorry
sorry
report me for what doing YouTube voice
um all right time to burn ourselves
it don't tempt me with a good time
it automatically spawns seven Bots good
I love reading all your comments
they're they're so cool you guys give
such good insight
all right
yo what up Rob how are you
agent
doing this with Ronnie's Hat's kind of
sick
foreign
those screams are crazy
how many people how many people leave
comments telling you that you're playing
the game wrong
listen the comments I get are like
they'll watch a lore video and they'll
say no this is wrong and that's it
they won't clarify or anything they just
there it is
let's be like
no I disagree and they don't say why
they're just gone
why is AGT stand for agent why not
Argentina you know what I'm Argentina
Jake it can be whatever you want I'm
America's Got Talent Jake
agent Jake Argentina Jake whatever you
want
agent of Russia
I don't want that right now
okay
yep you fall into the thing
let's see get these balls working
I wonder who's gonna be there for God's
skin Duo
we have yet to see the godskin duo so
I'm a little nervous for that
do I have sleep pots yet I don't that's
an issue
whoo
y'all be whatever you want as long as
you guys uh become members
and and smash that like button and make
sure to join the agency
probably making people on
undo their membership now
amazing
we already fought Rick unfortunately
is this guy replacing the Dragon
sick
hoslo armor
I think we can get spins out of this
I'm glad you like them Felix
definitely at least one spin right
yeah just one
where wow we are actually level 105.
holy [__] okay here we go
man holy decks
it's definitely uh
what we've gotten the most of
it
the funniest nickname you were ever
given
what were your nicknames I don't know
you're strong my build is [__]
terrible
as room roulette does
consistently
brother
I didn't grab the grace either because
he was up in my dick hole
no I don't have Bloodhounds Fang that
could actually be
a better weapon
if somebody uh helped Hideout he's
behind for sure oh I did grab it good
I thought I didn't
do I have blood ounce Fang I don't
no I don't
wee
you're beautiful
eat
Felix are you behind too
guys make sure to hit the live button so
you're not behind talking in a weird
time
yo what up Gumby
all right
I'm so confident
mm-hmm
therapy
Rune Arc it up [__]
hey way of the Lao thank you for two the
two dollar Super Chat I appreciate it
okay thank you
all right who we got
that is the most ominous thing I've ever
seen
look how creepy that is
that's one of the creepiest things I've
ever seen
holy [__]
I was on live yesterday and could gift
memberships from my phone but today but
can't today from your Channel
oh
um
why not
why not should be able to
I think the phone is just weird
it don't matter
all right
here we go
[Music]
man's just rolled three times
four times
five times
nope oh he got stuck in a roll dude oh
my God
he rolled five times in a row
if the memberships on mobile would bring
me to an irreversible crippling debt
all right how many of you guys can uh
and become a member or gift a member
right now
I just want to know if it's possible
excellent
yeah the room size kind of broke him
you don't have to do it but is it an
option for you to do so
also Trey I would click the go in the
description and click the join
thing
the join link
that might I think that's how you have
to do it on mobile
not that I'm saying you need to but uh
see if it's an option there
you are you're already a member though
I shouldn't have messed with you I'm
sorry puppy
it works
seems to be okay
cannot gift one
did you turn it on for yourself
to receive and you do so I don't
remember YouTube's so [__] weird with
this [__]
join link is fine no gifts though I I
don't get it
can can anyone see the membership
gifting option
I'm just curious
okay he's like stuck in infinite roles
that is not good
hey Liam did it
I appreciate the tarnish membership bro
thank you thank you
yes I'm on desktop okay I'm just making
sure it's an option that's all I want
thank you Liam
I appreciate you man
thank you thank you
yeah
listen you YouTube I I am uh convinced
even though I had a good conversation
with my partner manager
right now YouTube's live features are
kind of scuffed
but they're working on it
we'll see what happens in a couple years
okay
all right roly-poly time
maybe if I stay back yeah here we go
[Music]
did he just go outside
foreign
I
feel like they would make it easy
they should make it easy for you and
them to give you money yeah I know
your vods link is broken okay I'll fix
it
yeah it's it's doing what it did in
morgots Arena with the second phase fire
giant it just breaks them
more examples as to how the fire giant
is the most broken boss of all time
foreign
the most broken boss of all time
we're just uh we're just gonna keep
trying here folks oh we're jumping
no the Valiant gargoyles are dumb
not broken
big difference
listen the Valiant gargoyles is a broke
like not broken or
they're not broken they are an unfun
poorly designed fight whereas the fire
Giant's AI is consistently broken even
in the normal or
big difference folks
I'm at the back of your foot how are you
hitting me with your point
did either one of those work man
he's still not infected
wow
um
okay
no I like fighting gargoyles Cobalt the
Valiant gargoyles are stupid that's it
the the poison one the poison Duo fight
foreign
[Music]
that's the fight I mean okay you're just
[__] weird then
sorry to say
[Music]
this is just a luck best right here
folks
hey bungalist how are you
can can your can your foot come back
inside
thank you
foreign
oh my God this sucks
bro
what the hell do I do about that
I sat on the live channel for three to
four minutes before double taking
hey how did you do that if I wasn't live
there
okay
what hit
what dude
I was trying to find the stream having
seen the Discord announcement
oh okay I I figure people usually click
the link in the Discord do they not
because I always have a link to it
oh my God
I think I have a wet blade
[Music]
if I haven't gotten it yet I think it's
at the twin maidens
thank you
where did he go
bro bro
I don't know where he is
[Music]
oh God
be kind
foreign
we got good baby
fair enough give me a seed we don't need
anything else we have every seed in the
[__] game
that was some dumb [__] but we did it
that was some legitimate dumb [__]
can actually get more seeds that's
incredible to me okay
all right do you guys want the YouTuber
voice for these spins or no
YouTube voice or no
where we go
we get two spins
huge
gay or Nate
do the soft voice
all right we'll mix it up soft voice
what's going on gamers
it's your boy Jake
we got two spins
let's get it
been number one
oh please land on figure
oh my God
that kind of hurt a little bit
that kind of hurts
that's okay though
do Ronnie's voice
but a [__]
stupid int [__]
there we go
all right those were L spins L spins I
should have done the YouTuber voice
let's continue
on to malacath
you deserved all spins
Brady you enjoy anything I do
Ronnie voice for INT
intelligence
I heard tale of a tarnish hurtling about
the top of spectral steed
and upon looking into the Mata the talk
I surmise is of Thee Thou Art witness to
the power no
all fourth the spectral Steed named
torrent
that wasn't bad that was pretty good
if Ronnie was a dude
yeah what
please stop I thought that was pretty
good
George RR Martin will be interviewed on
Saturday for what
what's he doing
they must be done with a British accent
all right you [__] blokes you little
[__] bags we're gonna
isn't that Australian I don't know we
got two spinny spins here and a [__]
Rune bear in our face [__] that guy
yeah that's Australian
I'll go ahead and move through here as
fast as possible
Rocky
look at all this [__] lightning that
I originally thought came from a [__]
Dragon over here
apparently it's just
there's always [__] lightning here
and it doesn't come from the dragon at
all that's some [__] in my opinion
oh I'm [__] dead from a goddamn
kangaroo up on the hill amazing
[__] jumping Lobster up there I
didn't see
I can't do accents
get Lobster [__] oh okay
oh
nice lingering hitbox there yeah
sniper location up there
you guys [__] see that kangaroo up on
the hill oh ah that [__] was hot
what
Moving On Moving On Moving On Moving On
[Music]
dingo ate my baby
Charlie Charlie bit my finger
really
like really
[Music]
okay can I live from this like is this
possible
like if this guy decides to snipe me am
I just dead
nice went right back into me excellent
is this guy gonna disappear if I grab
this like the dragon does
specifically for the dragon oh we did
good
that's so weird
interesting
should we see the placidusac's
replacement the Placida sax replacement
I'm still getting used to uh
saying that name correctly
Placida sex
y sex
placidusax placidusacks
like
are you [__] kidding me
this one's huge
plus Sid you sex
nope I'm saying it how Smoketown says it
assiduous ax
classic dicks
okay
you know this place kind of [__] me
before but it's really on another level
right now
like this place was already kind of
crazy
there ain't no way man
oh God
he followed me from all the way up there
oh my God
he's still on me
like wowza
oh come on dude now he's gonna follow me
still
bro
man we really needed to get that
on the first go around here I don't know
how we're gonna get past the Lobster in
Norway
I think we're safe
from The Lobster at least
I didn't know they could jump down I
don't think they're supposed to
yo Robert Hernandez thank you
are you [__] serious
I wasn't even thinking of that guy
all right Robert thank you man I
appreciate it oh my God
I go this way or something
I mean I can
that was embarrassing your mom was
embarrassed last night
I won't tell you why
she don't want you to find out
what's the point of me doing this
you'll never know
might have been with me might not have
ooh somber nine
I hate it here
I forgot where you jump on the skip this
isn't even like I'm just gonna end up in
the same damn place
hold on
you died imagine typing that out instead
of being a member and actually using the
emote
lame
as that small dick no no no no
so you got it backwards
no no no no
check chess guys we don't need anything
else we just need to beat the game
we have got we have obtained everything
that we need okay
all right
we don't we don't need nothing
oh you [__] little [__]
[__] [__] bastard [__]
going the regular way again
foreign
why do these roar like these Bears have
Roars that go across
eons
like the Giants do
these repellent
I suppose I could have
does it repel lobsters
let's find out
leave me alone sir
good Vigor be inside the chest
no
it's not
what do I do about this Lobster
I like don't know what to do
[Music]
I it Snipes me Trey I can't do anything
there's a lobster
no
oh my God
all right
roll it up
roll baby roll
get me out of there please
[Music]
Jesus Christ dude
hey we got this Challenge on lock guys I
don't know who like
this is definitely gonna be God's skin
Duo right like I just have a feeling in
my mind that it's gonna be God's skin
Duo I can I can
it's there
I I feel the presence of it
oh yeah we are gonna go back down there
[__]
we already fought Melania
she's dead
I'm very smart
I am very smart
very smart
where's the other one
[Music]
really
look how much like no damage it does
there we go
yeah there's gonna be two phases as well
just want to point that out real quick
and they one shot me
good good okay yeah let's go [__] see
who's that class to do sexy first maybe
how about that
I like I knew it was common
I I did
oh now we gotta get past the lobster
again oh my God
yeah easy
why don't why the [__] do I talk like
it it waited until I didn't have stamina
anymore to snipe me
oh my God please be like the mimic tear
down here or something I don't know
what [__] it we're I'm
I don't care what's down there
we have everything we need
I'm just not dealing with the lobster
again
I think we could upgrade our weapons
potentially
um that seems like totally pointless
we could go try and find sleep pots
we have every other pot but sleep pots
excellent
this sucks
yeah I I thought I had that Dodge but he
delayed it even more than usual I think
metal turn this into a video
ah
we bought metal at PC and I've had
absolutely no work for her to do
thank you
listen I've tried doing stream
highlights videos before and they do so
bad it's it's weird so
I don't know
okay this is
kind of a lot guys
oh my God
oh
nice
oh yeah
room roulette did do well you're right
bro
that was like a challenge video
I was doing so good
I was doing so good for a second
this I think is just gonna suck balls
and there is still a fight after this
one
wow
if we get sleep pots
this fight's over
check after the spot try
they use the wrong theme song for these
guys
yeah the songs are randomized
all right
I do have Saint Trina's sword
would that just work
foreign
I could actually use these pillars a lot
better than I am
as well
what the [__] is that [__] it went right
through them man
yeah we might need to use Saint Trina's
sword here
definitely
okay
can I even use it
let me uh do this too
it's like a secondary
I can
okay
he has iframes in that move yeah [__]
apparently that's so dumb
any ashes do you mean any summons no
hell no
does this work just as well as the uh
the Sleep pots do
okay so that's not a time to do it got
it
it's way worse awesome
yes it takes like one sleep pot for it
to work usually
I was obviously a pretty bad attempt
why is the sword so bad
why is there only like one sleep weapon
kind of lame
I hope the DLC is all about dreams and
sleep stuff
bro [__] off
this fight is so bad
I feel like they really [__] up this
Duo fight I really do think that
God bro
this feels like it's not gonna work at
all I'm not gonna lie
most bosses only get a minor stagger
from sleep but it's a little bit more
useful than death play
rivers of blood would be cool
I'm going back to this I do not think
that's gonna work
should we look for the Sleep cookbook
I almost killed one of them
the satrine of Sword is just not very
good
holy [__] bro I haven't fought these
guys normally in a long time how the
[__] do you even do this normally oh my
God
I always use sleep pots every time I do
a normal playthrough
how do you even do this normally they're
both aggressive it's not like one [__]
off while the other attacks
they're both just always aggressive
okay without using a summon how do you
do it normally
I don't think that'd be any better than
the sword
good
what the
bro
this [__] sucks
all right we're looking up the I'm not
gonna
no this this ain't even worth to beat it
against the wall
okay where are my sleep pots what what's
the cookbook called
that we need
oh I don't even think we're gonna get
info on this by the way
uh
uh I know it's feathers but which one
is that the only one I don't know
uh
uh yeah the hit thing doesn't even tell
us where it is
so that's not good
unless that's another thing
I don't think it's telling us where it
is
slash give sleep pots yeah okay
yeah okay
iron wet blade memory stones smithing
Stone somber minor Bell bearing
it's for Bell bearings hints for key
items no
paints for
no
it's for Quest items and that's it
oh it does tell us hold on
uh
ever
is it fevers cookbook one
yeah
uh okay
oh where where is it
don't do this to me
replace his feathers cookbook one
uh
what
if it replaces it then that's not what
we need right
I'm going through all these these logs
are absolutely insane by the way
there's so much here
but I search the keyword
and now I can't find anything
[Music]
um
beverage cookbook won in Angel River
inch in a chest in a room at the top of
the flight of stairs and to the left
from Knox Stella's side of Grace
huh
Ansel River in a chest in the room at
the top of the Flight of the stairs to
the left from Knoxville estate of Grace
what
so
knock Stella side of Grace
wait there's two
where the Talisman that gives you two
extra spell slots I don't know where
that is either
didn't I already go up here
yeah I've already been in here
do I need to go in that room up there
it didn't say anything about using a
stone sword key
[Music]
the heck is this
oh my damage
foreign
well I'm gonna try it
I I don't know where that's telling me
to go actually
I really don't
oh my god of course
when do you [__] attack these things
I know I just use this key but I don't
think it's in there it didn't say
anything about using a key
set at the top of the stairs in a chest
but didn't I already go up here
didn't I already do all this [__]
[Music]
maybe I didn't grab the chest
foreign
I did
oh I'm still going
I don't think I've ever been up here
what the hell is this
that's a throne
those monsters or those big giants
bro please [__] chill
could be a weird movement
thank you
we're all throne
all right please be here
seed bed curse nope it's not this
what could it be referring to it said
knock Stella's side of Grace
there were technically two
sites of Grace
I didn't say specifically which one
yeah it might be next to the monster
cluster [__] I think you're right
I don't think I ever went in there
okay
I think I know what to do
so it's at the top of these stairs and
to the left
foreign
you just need to live somehow
I think it's in that room
there's 10 billion things in there man
should I just kill everything
I might have to
because it's just a little bit too nuts
man
[Music]
what in the [__] dick is hitting me
oh my God
couldn't even see that guy
dude all of the things in this area have
the most annoying attacks holy [__]
but Crow is slowly dying
yeah randomizer really uh
really doesn't want us to have
Fleet pots apparently
yeah there's definitely a rune bear up
there
foreign
[Music]
my God you little
Point Stone [__]
[Music]
I'm I'm digging how the crow just stays
right there like I love that
I'm getting hit by the arrows
now
oh my God
I'm trying to take this slow and it's
proving to be even more annoying
good
look at that thing spaz out
[Music]
oh didn't need this didn't need it
didn't need it didn't need it did not
need it oh my God
abusing the quit out
abusing it
oh I'm doing this right now
I hope they don't load back in
that is not what I wanted to drink dude
okay okay okay I'm going into this room
to hide for a second
I think
please let me in
yeah
why is it just constantly roaring bro
it's stock roaring
what
a [__] hitbox man what a great hitbox
there
Jesus Christ
[Music]
what are you saying what the [__] to me
I dodged it in this [__] roll that
staggered him into the wall killed me
all right
no I've tried the torch through this
area it doesn't do anything
before I remember doing that a few days
ago
oh my God this is crazy
what am I getting stuck on man
screw
yeah it might not even be in there
imagine if it's not
oh okay well we're gonna take advantage
of that he just jumped off a cliff why
did he do that I'll never know
hopefully that doesn't put him right
back there
it did I'm okay yeah okay I don't why
did I do that then
[Music]
I have assassin's Gambit
you put that on something
broadsword or something
yes I think I do yeah
how does this work
am I invisible now
[Music]
I've never used this before
foreign
harder to notice
I don't think these stairs are gonna
make a difference in terms of that I'm
not going to cap with you
open it open it
okay it's open
oh my God I just need to grab it I tried
to quit out and I it wouldn't let me I
already died
Felix I'm one common away from timing
you out for the rest of the day I don't
know what it is about you you pissed me
off
no [__] arrow man oh my God
is this like the worst Mosh Posh of of
enemies to have on a stairwell
I'm translucent for like half a second
oh I see I still am
[Music]
you [__] it
there it is
kill me Daddy
get me out of here
Jesus Christ
this guy I Felix I don't know never mind
your comments are just pissing me off
we got it
I don't know why I'm sitting down
three
go get more pots
hopefully we can find some or they have
some
one
two
we might need more later
let's try five
for now
that's not where I wanted to go I wanted
to go to the bridge that's where they
usually are
they're actually not that far away from
where they actually
should be
just realized that
not five two you're short on ingredients
I have never mind I
I have five in my inventory that's what
I meant
I just made three I made two more equals
five
should I just fight one
[Music]
foreign
I guess we can try and sleep him at the
same time
yeah if you guys don't know there is an
actual animation in the game where
they're supposed to wake each other up
but it doesn't work in their normal
normal Arena because there are other
enemies in the area
foreign
Blown Away
why are you backstepping fatty
trying to get him in the same spot and
they
really didn't want to
yeah it's a hidden mechanic
in the game
that I I don't know like did they just
like
did they realize oh it doesn't work in
the normal Arena well let's just leave
it that way
is that what they decided to do instead
of just like taking out the animation
entirely
that's so weird
if they didn't want it to do anything
and if they did wanted to do it why
didn't they fix it
right
I wanted to throw a pot
oh my God
cry
ing to throw it in between them
obviously
[Music]
okay
they're a little close for comfort here
really would like to kill you
oh my God this [__]
just that's the worst possible thing he
could have done
wow
now I'm out of pots even though it won't
even [__] matter
if it works don't touch it
I guess so
probably saw how bad the bosses were
after the game dropped and decided not
to
what is that what
I'm glad we took that like 45 minute DQ
DeTour for absolutely no reason though
good
It's gotta get good I guess
oh it's scared of me
now you guys want to Stack Up just fine
are these pillars gonna work well with
the ball here
at least the pillars are are nicer
I guess
I don't know what the other one's doing
and I'm fine with it
no oh you [__] delayed mother [__]
hell
oh my God
I don't I don't know what it is about
the skinny one
I still struggle to dodge some of its
attacks
three hours late on the notification
really
this sucks
straight
um
well the fat ones moves are like quite
literally easier to dodge for me
me personally anyway
I have used like rot or something
they're always just gonna throw their
fire at me when I do anything
because of the inputs
like they react to me doing something
with the fires
so
trying to think
could try and stick close to the pillar
or something like that
and use it
I don't know
foreign
They Don't Really separate though
they're just weird
and it won't matter because they can
just
they can do whatever they want when I'm
doing that attack unfortunately it might
be better to use the poison
Maybe
[Music]
how are you not poisoned
there you go
why are they throwing the fire so much
fatty don't want to cook
uh I thought I had the regular poison
out
whoops
come on fatty
did you poison too
there you go
almost protected not quite
it's just so risky
[Music]
I can't tell if they're double proc
though I don't think they are
the the God bro the fire is so annoying
let's do it whenever they want
's changing
I'm out of blue
yeah I hope phase two is like the mimics
here or something like I have to hope
for that
oh my God
foreign
might as well give it a try
let's take him over here
because yeah there's nowhere where they
can fall where you actually fight them
so
maybe it's just not in their AI to do so
I'm pretty sure
he was sidestepping there
yeah they can't fall
I don't think
he was like it was like a wall stopping
him from falling
YouTube videos and they're 40 second ads
is annoying
istg I'm about it I swear to God I'm
about to be heading the nearest
[__] I see
what the hell are you talking about just
skip it
or go get a water and come back Jesus
Christ
relax
foreign
oh I could upgrade
I don't have runes though I could go to
a mausoleum
I got the one down here
where's another one
this one
I could Parry them
I don't know I don't think that's gonna
be huge for us here
especially with two of them
if there's the one over here
are there really not that many
mausoleums I guess not
could go to this one
kind of a far run though
maybe I can just sell some stuff
I could try the serpent Hunter
yeah you can Parry him
you you can yeah
expensive
hmm
it strengthen these two
okay
foreign
that can be a plus 10.
I'm trying to finish today it's just
really hard at this point
uh
not gonna use any of these so might as
well right
what's 10 serpent on here
and then I need smithing Stone five
smithing Stone eights is that like
awesome
the serpent Hunter can be very good
that would have been nice a few seconds
ago
I say smithystone Eights
I doubt we're gonna find those that's
okay
let's try this
do our best I don't know this is this is
actually at this point since I can't
sleep them
a get good situation
hey we've had we it's been a very good
day up till right now
we found two great rooms back to back
you know
have I face Godfrey no I have faced
horror Lou though
yeah we have to beat these two and one
more boss right here because it's two
stages yeah
this is ridiculously hard right now
but hopefully there's a boss that I like
after this one
that's all I can hope for
foreign
they legitimately [__] up this fight
but you have to abuse it for it to be
anywhere near liable in my opinion
like they're both just aggressive
randomly it's not it's supposed to be
like an on and off thing right with the
duo fight
one attacks one comes at you they kind
of back off at different times
with this with these guys they're just
both doing whatever
at least that's how it was with
Ornstein smoke
[Music]
like that fight never felt unfair to me
as hard as it was
Jesus
I went for the big one oh
oh come on I'm trying to run to the side
and the camera won't [__] let me
come on
[Music]
thank you
oh
brother
that's right you have a tail attack
is he stuck in the same animation cycle
I swear he just did the same thing
four times
bro
[__]
like why did they make him roll for so
long man it's so dumb looking
he just rolls for
way too long in my opinion
like get get armored Core out so you can
fix this game
and give us more of it as I complain
about it
I don't want to sit here and just
complain about these guys but oh my God
fighting these guys straight up like
this with this amount of health is just
[__] torture
is that the case in this Arena Cobalt
because we have we have found in this
challenge that
the AI of bosses act differently based
on the size of the Arena
like the fire Giant in morgot Serena
thought I was so much further away than
I was that it spammed its long-range
attacks like [__] crazy even though I
was right next to it
so I don't know how they're being
affected yet but it the AI acts so weird
uh in this
yeah skinny is not [__] off there
he's just standing right next to him
gosh man
whatever
I try these again
this weapon's just too slow
poison just gets him to their second
stage faster
it doesn't really help us that much
kind of like when I don't want one of
them to get to a second stage almost
hey this is this is torture right now
though man
my bad
got way too greedy
they're so unhappy they're just like
um
I like that fight horror Chad
that one seems fair because one of them
kind of [__] off while the other one
attacks you and then they alternate
right
no I haven't checked that John I I it
would just take too long
there's also a [__] Lobster in the
doorway to get down there and it's just
like that's probably worse than this
it perfectly takes up the entirety of
the doorway
kind of crazy
thank you
okay
usually he stays in place there but that
time he kind of lunged at me to do that
maybe I wasn't far enough away
[Music]
originally they were both aggro
I mean I remember fighting them on
release my game Crash cool
man
um I play the game on release and they
like I beat them in the first like
couple days of the game being out the
duo down there
they were fine
hard but didn't seem like this unfair
so hard though
I really did not want this to take all
day
but this is kinda crazy
what am I doing
playing like [__]
they are definitely using the fire
attacks way more than they usually do
I think that's like the AI bugging
oh cool
nuts man
what challenge is this read the pin
comments
yeah
thank you
well seems like skinny is the aggro one
here I can't really tell
then I go in and eat man
[Music]
yeah I I think it's a uh
I think it's an AI thing
this fight's already annoying
but they're they're definitely one of
them's acting way more aggro than they
should be
they're all over each other too they
will not get off of each other
yes I'm still [__] here Gumby
foreign
way more
and it it makes the dodging like [__]
impossible
because like you you half the time one
Dodge but it'll just lead into the other
one's attack like it's so [__] hard
yeah we got the Sleep pots and they wake
each other up here so they don't help
thank you
[__] input reading [__] man
like the the other one just will not
[__] off
it's so bad
thank you
foreign
like come on cut me a [__] break dude
okay
yeah I'm trying to attack fatty but he
sometimes skinny comes out you just as
hard
yeah I'm surprised they made so many
adjustments to radon like how many times
did they buff in Nerf radon like three
or four times and they haven't [__]
touched these guys
since the game came out
and then they make Gideon the most
ridiculous [__] ever
and just left them like that I don't
know what they're doing
just couldn't care less
what the [__] am I supposed to do there
that's just so oh man like I have to
dodge the one I I guess I went in for it
mean
yeah I know people thought radon was
like way too hard on release but I
fought him on release before any type of
uh adjustment
he was not that bad
I bought him at like level 55 level 60 I
might have been over leveled a little
bit but
I don't know I didn't get what people
were saying with him at the time
he he was not that bad in my opinion he
was hard but
I thought he was fair
this fight's just torture to do without
sleep pods
the [__] does that mean Alexander
the fact he was nerfed only meant he was
too powerful to begin with
I what I'm saying is I don't I didn't
see that I thought he was fine
yeah and this boss is not optional
neither is Gideon and he's he's
ridiculous
I can't get an attack in when I should
be able to
because the other one's Throwing Fire
but [__] dude
[Music]
[__] you
thank you
no
he he just decided to go the like are
you [__] serious from software
you can just turn on a dime as a [__]
ball
[Music]
you're just gonna do it again huh
and it yeah and have them lag
as he's
[__] stop rolling holy [__]
what a dog [__] boss fight oh my god
dude this fight is ridiculous without
sleep pots
it's it's so dumb
oh I've called him fat many a times
but I have done this fight for the last
year probably with only sleep pots and
it's been great and now I'm dealing with
this [__]
When You Can't Sleep them
it's a nightmare
some Necromancer thing Gumby
some skeleton
oh
yeah this is only phase one
foreign
I'll have to clutch up with whoever's
after this
jump in the air
yeah
I thought he was behind the pillar
[__] man
[__] spamming Fireball [__]
that was the best attempt
uh he dropped like a somber eight and a
nine
especially really good
it's called an ant user
okay
foreign
belly roll right now
[Music]
would like to keep the other one in my
sights please
why are you not transforming
if I stay close to him does he always
jump up like this instead of doing ball
okay that's just snorly unlucky
I had to dodge the
explosive belly flop attack
and of course right at the end of the
frame
the other one is attacking me and at the
perfect time to kill me
I don't know breeb
did what
made the boss unfair
I don't know like
what I mean by unfair is like yes this
is obviously a damage check and a health
check you go and get more of those
what I mean by unfair with this fight is
that they don't do what a Duo fight
should do no matter what
one should kind of [__] off while the
other one attacks and they alternate and
this fight just does not do that at all
good example
that's what I mean
whereas like yes I could go get more
health and and more whatever but we're
doing a challenge so I can't do that
you have the speller Shield that turns
enemy spells and projectiles no I don't
I mean Korean retaliation no
I mean they they've done so much in this
game to make it where you can choose to
use summons and not to use summons
you should like they they did a lot to
make sure it was the choice of the
player whatever they wanted to do and it
should work
in this fight it just doesn't work
like they in my opinion they just [__]
it up like they did that's my fault
there but
oh
Noble
Noble usually only does roll attack
after you get his individual health down
to half
yeah I
yeah
we know
that's that's not the problem
I think the reason why it doesn't do
that is because they're both their own
enemies
bosses and by themselves their AI is
made to register well if they're going
to make a Duo boss fight with both of
them then they should probably change
the AI of them right
probably
if I had to guess that's probably a good
decision
they just didn't
like that is a perfect example right
there I have to dodge the other attack
but the other one can just do whatever
it wants and it can perfectly hit me at
the end of my role that I'm dodging from
the first attack
that's just [__] stupid
another good example
I
especially when you give me a tracking
Fireball to dodge as well
where I could move to the side but it
will find me anyway like holy [__]
it's a pain in the ass to change
they're from software look at what they
did
they can do it
they made the best game ever made
if you're going to make a Duo boss fight
I don't there shouldn't be an excuse
this is clearly not right
just like I think Gideon's AI isn't
right either now it's like a joke
or they don't care and they know it
like don't make excuses for the [__]
it's [__]
call it what they what it is so they can
make it better in the future
or they won't care that's probably more
the case
[Music]
foreign
what do you know about AI
holy [__]
like it's going so well until the other
one hits me at the end of my animation
dude
like what do you I I just don't get like
what do you mean by experience dude I
like yeah you're 14 years old have you
coded AI things in a video game maybe
you have
but you know like let's say you were
making a game would you just let your AI
be [__] stupid at one point in your
game probably not
that would make your game worse
like we're they're full-on Reddit
threads at how [__] the godskin duo
was when the game came out
I definitely remember the Reddit threads
man
and and those people who are complaining
got this far into the game it's not like
those there's terrible players that
didn't make it past Margot bitching and
moaning on on Reddit that we don't we
don't think about those guys but people
getting the godskin duo and complaining
which is more than like probably 85
percent of the game
no
like we we listen to those guys
could have been a late change why are we
making excuses for this
like I know it's from software and we
need to suck their dick but their game
needs updating and it's definitely not
radon like they've done four times
clearly they can change the AI
nice delay man holy [__]
like they they've proved that they can
change the AI of enemies man
for better and worse
no now I just feel like I'm sitting here
and bitching and moaning
I really like there's all of these
challenges always get to a point of
where it's just like oh my God
is just torture and not fun
what the heck does that even mean Bria
I'm giving them feedback to make their
game better agreed or not do you guys
think that changing the AI of the
godskin duo would make the game better
or worse
fix the game make it better
wait how is that how is that a like a
thing for me to not ask
you know
and we need to personally all uh email
Miyazaki because he'll he'll listen to
us
I'm saying it's easy for from software
to do well you wrote that out like you
said you also have to consider that they
have a team of developers and you are a
single person okay were you talking to
Gumby and not me like I can't tell there
if you were talking to me saying it's
easy to change it then okay like
all right
no no no Grim the boss is still dog [__]
even in its own Arena like and it's
still dog [__] even while using uh
not using sleep pots agreed
nobody likes the godskin duo fight even
when it's just normal Arena
like I know we're in a different Arena
but you get what I'm saying right
nobody likes this fight in the in the
normal Arena or anywhere
foreign
is I can't even see him okay
I'm still in the animation but I can't
do anything about that
died like four times that way
I'm still in the animation of my
tired
and the other one could just come out of
nowhere
you know like that [__] can happen just
in the normal fight as well
so that's what I meant grim
and honestly I haven't even thought
about this fight in the last year
because I've been using sleep pots the
whole time and it makes it way better
you know
but I doubt they designed it for us to
like go get sleep pots
yeah the rot's like unusable because
they just throw Fireballs at me when I
use it
[Music]
oh
I don't know what this is going to do to
his AI here look at that I cannot Dodge
that attack guys
because he's already in the middle of it
that's such [__]
God I hate that
I don't know why I did that
thank you
I can't
what the
explosion from him hits you
[Music]
I didn't know that
[__] you
frost spots aren't gonna do too much man
this is what we wanted from the start
come on
oh my [__]
I was spamming roll
I knew something dumb had to happen
I'm I'm stuck holy [__]
die die die
I think they're dead
please
please be something easy please
I I can't do this
please be something easy
fair enough
oh okay
they're all gonna hit me with fire and
I'm gonna die or some [__] I don't know
die kids
die
[Music]
I'm walking away from that
no
[Music]
she has a boatload of Health
I covered destined death
to kill what I'll say it
oh my God bro that was torture I hated
every second of that
I hated every second of that experience
yep first try
I knew I could do it once I killed one
of the godskin and then you can like
alternate killing each one if you get if
you do it right
so
that works
was it worse than first moon really no
first Rune first Rune roulette Millennia
fight was way worse that that was like I
was dealing with almost impossible
and I was bad at Millennia at the time
but the Flames I like this cutscene
who's gonna be at Gideon
farewell it is then I've heard Rune
level one is actually not that bad
we still need to do that you'll be Elden
Lord yet
Gideon Duo
yeah
we
we needed uh
we needed stage two to not be that big
of a deal there
Rune level one randomizer no [__]
thanks man
hold on
we're good okay
um the things I want to do next are
deathless all remembrances Oh wrong one
sorry
I want to do deathless all remembrances
I've done deathless any percent before
like three four times I want to do
deathless all remembrances I want to do
deathless
all bosses like I was doing I want to do
that
um
and then after that I want to do hit
lists
I would like to start doing hit lists we
get three spins
let's go
oh anus and a viewer solo the bosses
would be cool too
Ebon randomizer
and people know that would be [__]
impossible
probably
one
it was I mean it's possible like if you
use certain things
mind
[Applause]
um but I definitely want to I think if
to do the viewer run what I would want
to do
is I know there's a double mind wow okay
um I know you can like call in like with
the with the seamless Co-op you can get
like 16 people in at a time or even more
I think what I want like we could do
that but what I would want to do first
is like at call in
like every time I get to a boss I put
out a summon sign and you and I call in
one person at a time to see if they can
solo The Boss by themselves
and I I would literally just sit back
and watch
and we call in a different person each
time
because I think we've all gotten to a
point where we're all pretty good at the
game or we have like really good
characters or whatever
so that would be doable
we'd hunt for let me solo her
yeah is it cross-platform for people on
consoles just using summon signs
yeah it doesn't work
no you can't do that
there's no uh there's no uh
cross-platform in this game
before the Elden ring
I commend your spirit but alas
None Shall take the throne Queen Marcus
Allah hopes for us the
continue to struggle
onto eternity
oh there you are
what the hell was that bro
all right I'm I I'm
very comfortable with this
that intro was very interesting
yeah this is sewer Moog
you tell by the entrance
you a [__]
foreign
[Music]
no it's a Apparition it's not real it's
like a
like a summon or a clone
dude I got mowed down bro it's crazy
I got this fight down
foreign
[Applause]
why is he even there
stop us from getting to the frenzied
Flame
GG boys
I'll fight Moog anywhere anytime any day
I should do an all Moog run
every enemy in the game is moog
I do I think the summon in the sewers is
made by morgot not by Moog
just like yeah my brother's pretty
popular or pretty powerful
let's use it
yeah kind of like how let me solo her
did a millennia only run
exactly
maybe for Halloween
what's the scariest enemy in the game to
you guys let me level up as well
what's this
the scariest thing or the scariest enemy
in the game for you
maybe to pretend Moog is still down
there
oh
yeah revenants are pretty creepy
two spins
okay
Arcane kind of kind of worthless
the birds
oh no way heck yes dude
bigger
let's go
21 we still don't have as much Vigor as
we did in the original roon roulette we
had 25 in that one that was torture
all right anyone want to take guesses
we take any guesses
I'm gonna say
malacath yeah malachath
yes I got it right I [__] got it
right it's malachev yes
yeah
yes dude
is he gonna jump
this thought of that
any jump on anything in here
ah
it's not scripted I guessed
yeah does he just not jump that'd be
kind of interesting
I was too far away when he did that
attack
how much damage you're doing to him
malacath doesn't have that much health
sure shut the [__] up why would I script
the godskin duo fight
and and die there for two hours
shut up
you're 12.
oh no
oh my God
I hate that fight or that attack
it's awkward taco
I'm scared to tell Jake my age
let's be honest man
let's be honest
new enemy at half health no I think
we'll have another enemy
probably after a full kill here
maybe after half-held I don't know
you hacking heck
you're 23 I'm [__] 28.
I wish I was 23.
[Music]
is that a double stagger
oh you turned 23 that's fine
come on dude it's always right at the
end of that attack
I'm not dodging the spin I just died
three times
bro for real plays video games lives at
28.
what does that mean
I play video games for a living that's
[__] awesome
oh man
oh
thank you
damn I didn't think he'd do that
oh
20 in October nice
instead of a nine to five
how cringe is that yeah I know dude I
like how I'm getting [__] on by Scott
Sterling isn't that the guy who get like
slapped in the face by a soccer ball a
bunch of times Scott sterling sterling
somebody's projecting
bro plays video games at 28.
I bet you would want to you [__]
idiot
[Applause]
thank you
oh I don't have
stamina
I think it's better to do that
reposting's never worth it
[Music]
[__]
how do I get a girlfriend
um
I don't know
ask a girl you like on a date and um be
nice to her
it's probably pretty easy
you guys are just being mean to Scott
Sterling
I don't care
[Applause]
was that girlfriend invite was that good
girlfriend advice chat
Howie
come on I want to see who the next
person is
bring him on bring him on bring him on
give me [__] lewd Daddy
oh we already fought horror Loop
who we got
granola
I didn't roll [__]
oh she still does the thing
nice
foreign well we can get there I just
want to see who it was obviously
you know that's why I died it's not
because I didn't roll
just whatever you do don't take advice
from frog quad I'm on the internet trust
me bro call her disrespectful names and
show her you don't value her as a human
uh being bro it will work wonders trust
me bro
[Applause]
some Andrew Tate advice
is that guy going to jail now
all right
oh yeah again
[Music]
good point
no
oh they did no damage on the second one
foreign
[Music]
stop moving little bro
you're not him okay maybe you are
[__]
oh guys what were any of you surprised
that Andrew Tate's going to jail again
like really
I can I cannot believe people actually
listen to that guy
at any point in time
he did take he is him I I shouldn't have
said that
like it pretty much anyone who
yeah he did get out of jail but I think
he got indicted to go back into jail no
like he was found guilty of sex
trafficking like he's going to jail for
a long time now
the the people that listen to Andrew
Tate
were young and
rationable young young men
who got their heart broken by a girl
once and now they hate all women
that's it
oh
my God
he's moving like a crazy person
he's a master manipulator I don't
personally think so like
I'm not kidding you every time he opened
his mouth or or any time I saw him on
the internet I immediately thought to
myself what a [__] douchebag that's
what that's I have never thought any
other thought other than wow he is
actually just trying to get
pull out through like
uh
poorly in my opinion manipulating dumb
people
and and you know I'm not saying like
they were all dumb but they're all like
young impressionable kids
which honestly guys like
one under the age of 16.
honestly I could go all the way up to 18
maybe none of them are smart
dang it I need to focus
none of them are smart
I wasn't smart when I was 14 15 16.
nobody is it's you know you're
impressionable at that age
they're eat they're easily manipulated
because they don't know enough they're
they're young
but it's crazy how he like attacked that
and made so much money off it uh and now
he's gonna go to prison for probably
Billy's old
hope it was worth it
I actually don't
[Music]
all right we got this right here right
here
he is jumping around a lot
he's already old you know what I mean
like really old
[Music]
thank you
God I love Malika he's such a cool boss
yeah he may not get out of prison I
don't even know how long the sentence is
I don't know how Romania works
[Music]
you [__]
might actually be hard with this amount
of Health
yeah I don't think people some people
don't become smart well I I shouldn't
have used the word smart I'm more mean
like you're very easily impressionable
before you're like the age of 2025
you know
he's already out no no so yes he's out
of prison but he's going back to prison
now
foreign look it up
I I know he's out of prison now but he's
going back
[Applause]
okay calm down
I can't hit him
I can't hit him anymore
whoops
now look at them over here
oh
foreign
[Music]
stop moving
help
okay
36 is not old
I consider old once you hit
60.
I'd say 60.
I wouldn't call it old at all
for a rock at her
oh my
[Music]
foreign
damn
six is literally an elder you guys are
so I feel like all the pers people that
are saying 60 is elderly is like
are you guys like less than 20
you'll know what I mean when you hit 28
or like mid-20s
60 is not elderly my dad is 61 and he
does all kinds of [__] elderly is like
when you need help to do normal things
[Applause]
my dad is old
but he's not elderly
foreign
the rocket League Community if you're
over 18 years old you're considered old
damn he whipped that out for the first
time
[Music]
all the best players in the rocket
League Community are like
15 16.
then once he hit 18 20 you kind of kind
of fall off
you gotta have that uh
that young reaction time man
thank you
what
same thing happened
oldest player in rocket League still
goes to kindergarten yeah
are you guys saying that if you can
survive completely by yourself travel
cook and work out that means you're old
like
interesting
yeah it is dependent on uh like who
you're talking to like of course to a 15
year old a 30 year old is gonna seem
very old but they're not
thank you
you're 30 you're like probably looking
at a little bit above a third of your
lifespan
you still have two thirds to go that's
crazy
you know depending obviously
[Music]
man it's going crazy
the tail does not have a hitbox
all right Ronaldo be kind
I feel like Ronaldo is low-key kind of
hard without health
thoughts
[Music]
look at that how do I dodge that comes
out of nowhere
and I can't heal
there we go
[Music]
no she can still summon
that's not fair
[Music]
what's happening what's happening what's
happening she disappeared and came back
oh
her summons are under the ground
I'll take it
[Music]
she like farted
oh nice
the ice drinks
befits a crown
it looked like she farted okay
we're there folks we're at the end
finally man
we're there
we got some spinny spins let's get it
if she summons this game over she did it
wasn't that bad
all right we got three spins
go to Vigor go to go go go oh
it's not arcane
yeah whatever
yeah I think they've fell behind her
that's kind of funny
strength haven't gotten a lot of
strength in this run
I ain't gonna cap with you
and more Arcane okay
L spins
who haven't we fought yet chat who is
this about to be
we have two more
not both of deers have we fought God
trick
yes
I don't know
who's this gonna be guys oh we haven't
fought we're done yet one of these is
gonna be redone bro that's sick
um we've got redone we fought
it's it's literally a god-free radon
ending holy [__]
what an ending
I think it's gonna be Godfrey and radon
let's see
that would be a wicked ending dude we've
already fought Melania we've already
fought Nobles
I'm curious
there he is boys
oh
foreign
I'm old
oh
it's not good when you miss half your
attacks
this might not be the weapon for us here
guys
maybe it is
I'm curious if he'll even go phase two
damn it
if he does I am running to an edge
yeah that's not the weapon we want to
use that weapon was uh not very good
right there
um
[Music]
let's use
you know what
you know you know what
do I have a way to get out how do I how
do I go in somewhere wait wait wait I
know what to do
here I want to grab those runes do I
have one of those twigs
is that in here chat
what's it called a soccer soccer
sacked wig I don't have a swig I get
those and leave
hmm
if I go in there grab them and quit out
do I keep my runes
oh it's a talisman
really
it is holy [__]
okay
fair enough
I think they have to be main bosses Lord
for these once
I just wanted Daddy to kill me
you know
I just uh I just wanted Daddy to kill me
about this
okay so we got that
look how many [__] talismans we have
and we use this okay
um we all we still only have two
thousands by the way
we only have two crazy
okay
we can upgrade
some stuff I think
's gonna have a memory issue here
here we
what do you guys think serpent hunter or
the holy weapon I have
we can do either one
where is my serpent Hunter
not see it
oh no yeah it is quite oh it's already
fully upgraded that's why
oh
okay well we do this then
okay
what's better against radon
pulley or physical damage
yeah he was going off bro
rot I got that too
okay we'll use rot and serpent Hunter
we're gonna [__] end this [__]
over this challenge bro
you guys remember when I took seven
hours to beat Melania and then I went on
to beat the rest of the game in like an
hour
uh the camera does not want to work okay
cool
I pressed the camera button and it
didn't work and I actually like stopped
thinking about anything
so weird
yeah I ended that guy's career didn't I
okay now we're gonna
now we're gonna go in and do it
that that didn't count that was a bad
attempt
I really hope it's God free in the next
stage
it is
oh my God
that hurt my soul a little bit
Jesus Christ
wow
no I I did not finish Dungeon Crawler
mod that could be fun to do
you guys think I should continue these
streams here or on kick
I've been thinking about just going all
out streaming on Kik even the Elden ring
challenges and just putting them on the
bod Channel
um and then working on the fallen leaves
for this channel obviously
Kick's been great man I've been having a
lot of fun with it
now simulcasting is way too sketchy
a Dodge Journey
it's very very sketchy
yeah I streamed on Kick yesterday uh
that only up game
very fun
your only way to view you is YouTuber
twitch why is that
I I do not like twitch
I haven't for a long time
oh I do have a sister's hat
he's so mad
jump
[__]
foreign
oh he's still jumping
go to an edge go to an edge go to an
edge
[Music]
I'm scared
damn it
he's rotted though
[Music]
damn
oh kick isn't on PlayStation and I don't
have the computer unless it's an app
then I could use on my phone there is an
app on the phone
that you can use
yeah there's a way better money split on
Kick and the emotes are really good
the quality is better on YouTube though
both hazards ups and downs
I just personally think that like
YouTube does not
have like a streaming culture
it's like impossible to grow
from streaming
all right
however they did make a shorts culture
oh my God he's going crazy right now
um they got rid of their reactions yeah
Gumby
but I still think there's like a quick
thing for the emotes
but there's no like reactions to
comments that's what you mean
yeah I mean like
here's what I think of like streaming
wise right I think of streaming as it
needs a good ecosystem for people to to
grow off of
which
you can do on Twitch it's just really
hard because twitch is obnoxiously
saturated with streamers you guys notice
that like if you go to any category of
game or whatever on Twitch there's
millions of streamers right Millions bro
like they're they're so there's more
people streaming on Twitch than there
are viewers sometimes like it's crazy
right
um so you're just like if you're in that
lower tier or that mid-tier of viewers
on Twitch you are [__] unless you use
like
I don't know
freaking uh Tick Tock live at the same
time to grow so people can actually see
you and then come in
because they're randomly giving uh
getting found on the feet of their Tick
Tock or whatever
that's what I did on Kik yesterday for
the only up thing I randomly got 600
viewers on a tick tock live and they all
came over to kick not all of them but
some of them did but they you know just
the fact that some of them did is cool
kind of the same thing on Kik
where I don't know how many viewers they
have but with YouTube
have you guys ever been like you go to
the live tab on YouTube it is weird like
it's not normal
the only time I ever watch
I did finish only up the only time I
ever watch a streamer is because I
already follow them you know what I mean
like I already watched their videos and
I randomly see oh they're streaming
that's cool
it's not because I was in the live tab
does that make sense
where you would want it to be because
they're in the live tab
no I didn't roll bro I'm playing so bad
yeah that's xqc Lord he's he's dumb
sometimes
but he's also rich
all I get in the live tab is Ludwig and
the monster Minecraft monster school I
don't know what that is
legitimately the emotes are really good
on Kik they are
like yesterday's stream was great I had
a great time
it's just a different vibe
you know
what the oh I didn't have stamina
that was uh close
[Music]
foreign
it's
[Music]
never worth it to repost
that's an odd attack
very rare
I'm struggling with her Dawn here man he
has a boatload of Health here
a boatload
should I go back to the balls
yeah those hit me because of the thingy
the uh
the lightning upgrade to him
something along those lines
it's going David
trying to finish it off
was that a kick alert
did somebody follow on kicked
I don't know why I can hear those
oh thank you Robert
bro holy [__]
it shouldn't be able to hear that but I
guess we can
holy [__] man radon is kicking my butt
right now
I miss cat Jam
yeah cat Jam is fun
what I need to do is try things for a
little bit longer periods of time
I bounce around too much
it's at uh the pin comment David
oh
oh my God bro I just didn't roll in time
that's it
still got ratcham dude I'm pretty sure
um
I'm pretty sure cat Jam is on kick
go check it should be a global emote
exactly Suka that's what I was talking
about
which doesn't really create a very good
ecosystem it's just like who if you
already have a fan base sure do it you
know like
who are the biggest streamers on YouTube
dim the tap man
uh
doctor disrespect Ludwig
saikuno
Valkyrie
some others I'm not thinking of they
already had very established YouTube
communities
of millions of people and they get 20
000 of them come to a stream
you know what I mean
oh yeah
the hitbox here is not fun folks
foreign
[Music]
wow
and if you go it and honestly like the
most viewed streams on YouTube are like
mobile games
where I'm like oh God
gross
get back to the serpent Hunter
should I try the holy weapon
I feel like I might be getting gas lit
by y'all right now and like maybe it's
not that bad
I'm trying to use the rot I just have to
use it a very specific time
oh yeah that's [__] terrible
yeah that's really bad guys
yeah that's that's not good
come on
damn it I'm not good enough
top one on the home page uh on Kick is
amarath with a bikini of course it is
she just signed a kick
you got um a big deal to go to kick
my guess is 25 million
although it was in it was indisclosed
amount of money to go to kick
hey Gumby it's not hard to just not
click the girl in the Bikini man if you
don't want to watch it okay
I know you're I know you're 12 and
you're and you're quite horny but you
can calm down bud
foreign
why does he have no feet either scraping
through the sand for so long uh scraped
off his feet and then probably a little
bit of that and the the rot
eating away at him
probably a little bit of both
what
holy [__] bro he's going crazy
no cat Jam I'm pretty sure there's cat
Jam
um if we enable like a better TTV
which I do
but you have to do the same
back in 14 it's it's really not a
difference man
sometimes I confuse by Felix messages uh
Felix is a little weird
okay
what is going on
he is very aggressive
keep [__] up too
give me a moment sir
thank you
all right
I don't even know if this will work
[Music]
he can fall off unfortunately
oh that's kind of dumb I needed to jump
[Music]
uh sure Stumpy
sure man
I just want to see who's stage two
yeah I can't even fall off the edge he
is flying through the sky though so
that's a little different
you know
foreign
[Music]
did we die for a second
OBS stopped working for no reason okay
are we good
what happened why does OBS [__] do
that bro it's so weird
refresh refresh
weird
well
all right we good we good
I think it's going to be a Godfrey phase
one in uh the second stage
we already fought the Eldon Beast where
uh the Miss begotten is in Weeping
Peninsula that was crazy
then down to 240p
is sometimes OBS just like I'm not gonna
work right now
foreign
I think he was at one of the deer places
[Music]
I don't remember
bro this is [__] so hard oh my gosh
I think I have fought Market
Somewhere Out There
we fought morgot
I don't know about Market actually
now technically
Godfrey could be like where the Halo
tree is
we don't know
Sophia's Champions was where radon is we
already fought him
they were the replacement for Radon
dude I'm usually so good against radon
and I am getting my ass kicked right now
bro
I wish the camera was a little bit
higher
like it is in the fight but I don't
think we're gonna get that here
I think we already fought regular
roulette rolletta Stone
I don't know we'll find out
right
if I can freaking beat this guy
looks pretty nice out man I want to go
hit golf balls
I can't do camera off
a bit too AKO taco
[Music]
man he can just turn that [__] around
and [__] kill me
yeah Felix that's just a really dumb
message man he retracts like almost
everything he says why are you doing
that
yeah this grunts are scary
he's like you didn't upgrade Vigor
enough no [__] dude
that have to be a little luck involved
man
did you realize your message was a
little dumb
it's okay
bro I keep think he's gonna do something
else
how did that Miss
Ed big risk there
[Music]
um [__]
foreign
I do always try to run to the edge
[Music]
ah
yeah we've beaten both Estelle's and
both ancestor spirits
I was doing so good on that attempt man
that like rap like that swing around his
whole body turn thing he does is so
[__] hard to dodge
hey you know what the solution is more
vigor
where I don't die in one measly hit
[Music]
yeah that attack right there is
ridiculously hard to dodge
haven't been hit by that by yet okay
we're just learning everything about
every boss is AI in this game it's great
it's amazing having a good time my goal
was to do this in three and a half hours
today by the way guys that was my goal
in my head and we're all we're running
up on six
I set a goal in my head I'm thinking
three and a half we're running up on six
amazing
very good
my whole day gone
just kidding
bro I've stood under that attack every
[__] time and it doesn't hit me
yeah
wow bro that attack is so insanely fast
Bubba
Obama
I don't know what's coming out of my
mouth right now some crazy [__]
should I just try to to Decay him now
I haven't done that yet
I keep looking for that second wave
opportunity to do it and it's not really
happening
oh
man he he whipped his fat dick out of
his pants and slapped it in my face
wow
that just hurt
oh my god dude okay is he not being more
aggressive than usual
foreign
gets [__] crazy
when they're not in their normal spot
[__]
Canberra Don be poisoned
I think he can he can be poisoned and
rotted
we're making this harder than it needs
to be folks
we'll poison him first wait for an
opportunity to rot him as well
and then he dies
thoughts
comments concerns
we do that
yeah there it is okay
not hard to get him poisoned
the rot takes a very specific
opportunity
I am really struggling with that attack
poison was looking good maybe we just do
the poison
for now and hit him with my stick
at least the poison is is gettable and
the dragon isn't this crazy uh animation
that
makes it so easy for everything to hit
me
we're working through the problem right
now
working through it
like a g
dude
he is [__] crazy in here I'm sorry
he really is being like obnoxious
I need my bloodhound
that's what I need
bloodhounds
finesse
uh-huh caught you that time [__]
face poison
I'm sorry but how do you dodge that
attack
I actually don't know right now
spins around and just seems to always
hit me
he's going [__] crazy dude oh my God
yes you can
right
oh
it's not what we were looking for there
folks
I'm just noticing that that poison is
basically doing nothing
have a good one copper
oh
no you can I can usually Dodge
everything off the horse I just don't
know why that spin around attack is
hitting me oh for
I don't know why
I've never even thought of that attack
before today
I think we gotta rot him because the
poison does like basically nothing
but I can't
do this animation man you it's just
crazy look at his little
he's just scooting around on his little
horse scooter
like a crazy man
he's really kicking my ass man it's kind
of demoralizing right now
foreign
what the [__] do I do about that it
covers the entirety of the area
okay Felix I'm timing you out for the
day
I'm back tomorrow when you're not being
weird
he probably won't go to kicks who cares
lightning it won't make a difference
we're trying to proc them for something
I'm I'm waiting I want him to do like
the jump attack that's a good that's a
good moment to use the rot and then the
big load up but he's not doing it right
now which really sucks
foreign
it sucks that I you know pretty much
every attack he has I die in one hit
this one
we're looking for that one
okay why did I dodge at that time
why
isn't that time
oh [__]
okay wouldn't have mattered
foreign
there we go
no
no what the [__]
[Music]
I think I got him doubled up
yeah he's doubled up
he's doubled up boys
[Music]
that was a little closer Comfort
how did that Miss
foreign
that attack was so fast man
look at him just die too [__]
give me the controller I'll kill him go
do your own stream and do it yourself
how about that
have a great day Vigo
okay that's the that's the move though
we did it right we just gotta do it
better
no I don't Gumby
Gumby stop being 12 and purposely
pissing me off with your questions today
all right
[__]
foreign
like if you want me to call you 14
then stop making me think you're 12.
cut it out
you didn't actually piss me off oh my
God never mind
okay
not what I wanted to do there
hey Finn how are you
I never thought I'd struggle with radon
but he is like
is he definitely like am I just
I don't know
I don't think he's more aggressive than
he usually is but he definitely seems
like it
okay bye Gumby Jesus Christ dude
all right I
I'm being mad at Gumby for no reason
yeah maybe it's the arena
oh it was so close to being able to
dodge as well
yeah I dodged it
dude if that animation didn't take an
hour and a half
oh my God and of course he does like
that perfect back
stab thing whatever
never seen people get off Gumby wasn't
trying to ruin my day guys he Gumby
makes comments at the worst times
consistently
that's why I get a little irritated with
them sometimes it's fine it's not his
fault I'm still gonna get mad at him
though a little bit
he's got 12 year old timing that's it
what was that attack
should not have done it
yeah he still has meteor
maybe your stats are just crap so it
feels Wilder
um well you know what it is is that I
don't have enough Vigor to survive a hit
however
I should be doing this without getting
hit
um
and I'm really struggling with that
because
he he doesn't seem more aggressive in in
the only way he does seem more
aggressive is that I think he's chaining
combos together way quicker than he
usually does and I think it has to do
with the like the size of the Arena
like he'll go from ending a combo to an
immediate other attack way faster than
he does in his own Arena
while the attacks are still like pretty
normal
foreign
still didn't get them I used all of it
bro
there we go
he's double stacked
[Music]
use this to get the proc longer right
even though he's gonna jump here
we just gotta survive
[Music]
foreign
why did he just pull that out he's dead
look at that [__] he's dead as hell
I didn't think he'd just go bam right
away dude
oh my God
he just whips that out like it's it's
one of the fastest attacks in the game I
swear to God it is so hard to read him
doing that
Ian
that's it though we we got this we can
do this hit list if we want to right now
we got the plan
come on
no
my fault shouldn't have done it
oh it procked him too dang
that was fast look at him run around
he's doing his little runs
dude I wanna I guess it's hot today
whatever
again my plan was to do this in three
and a half hours today chat we are over
six
these challenges always proved uh just
there's always like one or two things
that proved to be the majority of the
challenge
that was God skin Duo and this
oh I'm holding it down for too long
that's what it is
that [__] glided in a weird-ass
way to get over to me there wow okay
Leonard wanted me dead there
he he glided him over to me
that looks so weird
come on
do the thing man
do the thing
I thought I was close enough man
what are these attacks
I'm too impatient
foreign
I have to wait for either the jump or
the big load up attack
there is no other thing to do it
there's no other time to do the thing
I can do the poison whenever this the
rot is really hard to pull off here
is this too fast
this is phase one we don't know what
phase two yet is
we don't know
there
okay there's one proc
for one little steple
do something I want
jump
yeah even the Jump's not a good one to
do it on
that's what we want
okay like that just hits me that time I
guess whatever
Dodge it a million times and then you
get hit by it once
and then I get impatient
I would love a rock variant of the Miss
bro the only issue with this is that the
animation to do the Scarlet rot takes
way too [__] long
it's such an obnoxious animation but it
is really cool
come on
we had him bro that that last good
attempt I had that was it
we had him man
we really did
like do any other attack and I can dodge
it there you little forehead
hey Aaron
how are you
he's gonna say tired
I guess I'm getting hit by that now
okay well great
I think I'm too far away I'm not as
close as I think I am there
isn't there a rock pot oh I'm sure there
is
a bit sleepy
yeah I knew you're gonna say that
the last three streams you'll say is
that Jake
and then you say I and then I say hey
Aaron how are you and you say sleepy and
then you don't talk anymore
have to read your mind that's just what
that's what's happened the last three
days
I hope you're doing good
see that time I was like right up in his
dick
called out and it's not a call you're
fine it's not a it's not a bad thing
brother
guys why is this so hard right now
rock you bastard he won't rock man
oh my God
but no I'm not calling you out I'm just
saying that's what's been happening last
three days
at least he's not using the bow and
arrow moves
the meteor's fine we've dodged it we've
almost killed him twice
just just getting the Scarlet Rock prod
is so annoying
there's there's no windows to do it
I'm looking for new ones here clearly
okay
that's not a time to do it
and maybe it is
that's it baby
that's what we like to see baby
what was that
different variation of that attack
what
I've never seen him do that before
he usually pulls his blades up like this
and this time he was like this
what the hell
[__]
ah we finally got it and it just
yeah a lot of people don't notice in the
other Arena Solaris that he has no feet
a lot of people don't even notice it I
wonder why
I'll take the hit [__]
can't see
dude this one went out
is he double proc chat I don't want to
look
I gotta heal so bad
I think so
I'm fine with this
[Music]
foreign
there just to maybe just a hair
[Music]
just to tickle
why did that Miss
why did that hit me oh no we'll never
know whatever doesn't matter
why is he not proct anymore
I need it
okay this is the jump right yeah
no I forgot he throws him oh
I've totally forgot he throws the Rocks
man
I was just waiting to for him to jump so
I could jump
that's all I was looking at
oh my goodness
this is harder than the god skin right
now
outer God of gravity
no
there is no outer God of gravity
give me a [__] break here man
now I'm too late to this which is a good
time to do it but I can't now
I tickled him
[Music]
foreign
oh my God
I shouldn't have done it
thank you
[__]
God calm down a little bit man
[Music]
fart juice everywhere man
it missed that might have staggered him
and he's dead if it does
[Music]
I'm very stressed right now
I don't know if you could tell
he just whipped
god dude he's so aggressive it's insane
it's a whole [__] aggressive
I've never seen him like look this way
and just go
like that
Jesus
man
it's so hard
he does crazy moves the closer you get
to him I mean
I have I have hundreds of hours of
footage of how of proof that bosses in
this game
do the craziest [__] when they're low on
health it's blatantly obvious
I did not feel like I was too close
there
maybe it's the wall behind me I don't
know
it might be the wall behind me [__]
me there sometimes
like his sword is getting stuck on the
wall because there's that invisible wall
and then it's like gliding down and
hitting me
I don't know
it's not ring it's struggle go Jay
the struggle Avi thank you for the 10
super chat that's very nice of you
how are you
thank you man
appreciate you
it is the struggle right now
we are struggling heavily
yeah oh it comes out of nowhere
Jesus
they should go through invisible walls
I'm just trying to think of a reason I'm
getting hit sometimes when I do that
because
I I made sure I was close enough and I
just wasn't
favorite Doritos flavor purple bag
easy
redone is arena is a bizarre yeah it is
he's acting really weird in here too
he's very aggressive
oh that was a good variation of that
why is that hitting me I think the
dragon is Lifting me up
that's what it is
the dragon lifts you up in the air
doesn't it oh
oh
that's what it is
I'm like trying to think like why is
this randomly hitting me sometimes
that's why
got it
I think that means I have to wait a
second like
a 10 milliseconds it's
ah dude the fact that I have to think
about that right now is insane
no
yeah purple bag Doritos I think that's
spicy nacho is that is that it
is that spicy nacho flavor
I'm in there like swimwear
I am really
having a tough time right now man
I'm dead
I'm alive
I healed through it let's go
come on
foreign
Cape Cod sweat what the [__] is that
Oh cape cod's sweet sorry
no I haven't tried spicy jalapeno either
I don't really eat chips
anymore I used to though
oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh my God
you're gonna do something dumb
just die
no my thank God
and now we gotta do something else
please please be easy please be easy
please be easy
Loretta
oh I hate this
I do not like Loretta
oh she's got hella Health bro
[__]
oh my God
she does all my health and she's got
tons of help
thank you
this is insanely difficult Chet oh no
um
in Loretta be poisoned question
and she be rotted it's just oh my God I
am
she might be harder than radon I'm not
even joking right now
I am actually not kidding she might be
harder than radon
here
with that much health
both yes
I can rotter when she's staggered maybe
just thinking of the timing on that
right
foreign
she's weak against lightning really
[Music]
okay well that was the best we're gone
we've had like we were literally about
to do that without even healing okay
um
what did I do different there I ran to
the [__] side God [__] this game and
it's weird RNG sometimes
add that
weak against lightning if you can use
the lightning bolt
come on
what the [__] is he doing what was that
attacks have never seen God damn
you might want to get more blue if I
want a lightning Loretta to death
maybe lightning poison rotter when she's
staggered Maybe
has grown afraid of you I'm just
surprised I'm struggling so much
like this challenge is making me like
I think I did not get better at the game
recently
okay
did he [__] delay that
that felt delayed man like does he have
a different variation of timing on that
attack
it dodged that 99 of the time and
sometimes I'm just like what the [__]
maybe I dodged you early I don't [__]
know anymore
or Jake will do a god run where did you
hear this
he's looking over here and Swinging like
this way I don't get it
from my manager who's my manager
Ertel Pope
after I do the last two deathless things
I want to do I'm gonna do uh
uh I was gonna try hitless any percent
but I want to finish the two death
deathless runs that I have left
Metal's my manager
I didn't know this
[__] proc man
literally seen attacks I've never seen
awesome
[Music]
or attack combos at least
gotta love it man
oh my God I don't
this is taking way longer than I thought
it would
way longer
the uh the the low health
is is getting me again
[Music]
um I don't think I ever finished room
level one
that was like a year ago
I got distracted by something else
pretty sure
it's dude
[Music]
this is a really getting on my nerves
right now
I feel like I should have finished this
a long time ago
come on
um but I should do that too we're in
level one
we have deathless all remembrances
deathless all bosses Rune level one hit
lists any percent those are like the
four I have on my mind right now
he he just did he's done a full minute
of combos I've never [__] seen before
this is crazy
oh
zero opportunity to do any procking
there
we'll just get hit
no I got it I I got it
I don't know which one would you want
first
which challenge
I'm probably gonna start doing them all
on Kik
did it just tell you that metal
for real
awesome
green level one okay
we can do that
and high metal
I'm getting frustrated
I was trying to be nice since you said
I've been mean oh okay
because I only said that because someone
in chat earlier like said that they got
notified four hours in
it's like oh
so we just got another twitch here
remember twitch would notify my
followers that I was live like four
hours into every stream
okay at least I'm not dead
you got any ideas John
dude he is acting actually [__] weird
like he is
how are you not crocked yet man
[Music]
foreign
I think I was taking too long in between
Rock attempts
buggy enemy Rando that's a good one we
could do
I did see there was a fog gay one big
how did it how the [__] did Jake know
I'm not as a manager dog you talk to me
like every three weeks I guess that is
like my manager
please do Aaron I appreciate that
self burn how is that a self burn
foreign
I and that's because they talk to me
every three weeks
I don't like that
I did have a management team
um they went on a spurt of not talking
to me for three months
so I said hey guys
I'm out and they're like what what do
you mean
like guys
don't talk to me I'm out
about you every day if I didn't struggle
to get out of bed every day
well okay
here's a good reason to get out of bed
every day talk to me
I expect a good morning text when you
wake up every [__] day
from now on
I don't care if you wake up at two
or four pm
I expect the text thank you
how did we have such a good attempt and
now these are all [__] trash
the Elder ring for the first time today
congratulations zyper good for you
Gigi this is a cipher
oh we should write down that viewer run
too I'll just have the viewers uh
beat every boss for me
thanks blood
sounds good man I will say pipe the
majority of these challenges will be on
Kick from now on after today
oh my God bro like I don't think I can
[__] do this guys I really don't
this is getting insane
this is this is the most aggressive
radon since I've seen the release of the
game like this is actually [__] crazy
yeah the vods will always go on YouTube
of course
as long as they're not uh dmca
I need to figure a way to to
separate my Spotify music from the vods
that I record I definitely can do that
I just need to figure out how
cool I just didn't [__] roll even
though I pressed the button I simply
just didn't
all right he's proced but I'm dead
oh that would be great nettle
as I would love to listen to some funky
beats right now but I can't because
YouTube and it's
dmca
insane tracks
yeah independent audio tracks it
wouldn't even be removed from the bot
they just wouldn't be on the bot at all
you'd hear it on the stream live but you
just wouldn't hear any music
oh [__] I guess I'm poisoning you first
I didn't even mean to do that
dude my eyes are starting to not work
bro
if that didn't proc them twice okay it
did
foreign
why didn't he do the slam did he do it
or not I didn't even see it
did he do the slam
doesn't he go whoop bang did he do that
you've been scared to scream for six
hours seven
yes
did he do it did he do the slam that he
always does there
someone rewind I I know none of y'all
are even watching you're just listening
but
foreign
this is [__]
I thought the godskin duo was gonna be
like Orchard and this is close to it
did I just hit him should I stop trying
to do this proc thing
no it works so well when you when it
works man
he did not
so I got
so I got [__] awesome
amazing
he just the AI just randomly decided to
not do the scripted thing he always does
that's great
I like literally can't have that happen
with
it
I'm pressing the roll button
and it's just simply doing nothing
[Music]
what the [__] is that did you see that
God he's so aggressive he's so weird
this went from one side ran around and
flipped to the other
God I have beaten radon hundreds of
times and this is the most ridiculous
version
this is the most ridiculous version I've
ever seen of him dude
huh
[__]
foreign
there it was again I guess he does that
nice
so right here he just didn't do the slam
before straight up just didn't [__]
do it
big bleed big bleed
foreign
make sure you have a connected phone
number Robert or it won't let you join
I felt like I wasn't even near that what
the actual [__]
he was dead too [__]
you have to have a connected phone
number will not let you join
I was not even [__] near that dude
and it's killed that's done that to me
twice now
metal I was here for an hour and a half
before you even showed up so it's not
you
thank you
I'm just like taking more hits here
because I'm just so [__] impatient
there's just like no opportunities to do
this thing man I'm so impatient I just
want to proc them and then get it over
with
and
but he he has like one opening to do it
we're still going man I read the title
it I'm not stopping till I beat it this
is this is the last thing I gotta do
man
oh
metal you want to do a video for this
[__]
I'm dead
oh my God
thanks Aaron
that was getting sniped by a lobster
earlier that was [__] great
I mean the last Rune roulette video we
did
did great
at like almost 100 000 views it's the
only challenge video that's done well on
the channel
this is roon roulette randomizer
it's driving me [__] insane
dude like [__] off man
oh my God
I'm I'm losing my cool chat I lost my
cool for a while but
I'm genuinely thinking I might not be
able to do this like that's where I'm at
I've I've never thought that way in like
six months
and and right now I'm like I don't think
I can do this I cannot I cannot preface
this enough to you
how [__] hard this is like I have
mastered this game in so many different
ways
lately
this is the most aggressive radon I have
ever [__] seen
and I don't think you'd be able to
notice it
unless you were playing right now
like
the the timing of this attack in
particular does not work that's it it
doesn't work it doesn't
it's a Non-Stop combo machine and I get
one tap by [__] everything this is
crazy
there's no opportunity to hit the guy
almost
no don't start with the [__] chat don't
tell me just take a break don't tell me
to stop I won't I'm gonna complain
though
I've seen the roll button you [__]
game
are you not procked
ow I hurt my [__] hand oh
who plays Mortal Kombat 11. I'm sorry
and the the attempt after I got to
Loretta
was perfect and every
the last two dozen attempts after that
not working
game we're all on currently because it's
only ten dollars that's cool
yeah radon's the [__] album Lord
for sure
he did it
he can he can [__] be Eldon Lord I
don't care
I was just hoping in my bones that I
might be able to get an attack off there
and I can't
all right
that's cutting it about as close as I
can
right here
is he proc double Crocs I think so
foreign
why is he not doing the slam anymore why
not
what the [__] it's it's like the only
good opportunities to hit the guy
he's supposed after he slams into like
he grabs the rocks from the ground he's
supposed to rise up into the air and do
a giant slam and the last two times I've
gotten him there
he doesn't do it anymore
I don't understand why not
he just decides not to
foreign
[__]
dude give me a fully upgraded
Bloodhounds Fang in this guy's dead in
10 seconds
no idea where it is though
did I get there to Loretta with the
balls
or with the serpent Hunter
I don't know
oh
foreign
going to the poison
I think a bunch of people's memberships
just renewed
I don't think they're actually here is
he gonna do it there you go
that's what we want
[Music]
oh I got the bleed too
please don't kill me
[Music]
okay running to the side
just it just randomly killed me [__]
twice good to know
[Music]
no no no no no
die
[Music]
thanks for all the uh the re memberships
guys
uh you said lightning right
guys that didn't do [__]
nope that ain't it
[Music]
really
no please keep doing it
no
what do I do
oh
this this feels impossible I'm not gonna
lie like I'm I'm at a point of like
this is just [__] insane she has an
absurd amount of Health
it is like a ridiculous amount of Health
holy [__] so does Radon
I I just gotta hit her with the balls
man and not get hit like there's no
other option
[__] me man
ah
I mean I pretty much almost did that
last attempt hitless Robert so I mean I
had seven
seven pots left that's fine it's just
the fact that she has so much [__]
health and I get one hit by everything
this is so [__] stupid
at this point
foreign
like it doesn't matter that Loretta's
I'm dead I don't know why I did that
um I was already thinking of something
else yes she's she's weak to lightning
but it doesn't matter because she has an
absurd amount of Health
oh like
because she's
Eldon B specked you know or whatever
so like yeah I can throw 15 000 light
bulb lightning bolts at her and it might
do more damage than something else but
it's not gonna matter
foreign
I don't have enough Blue by what a
millimeter
[Music]
all right
he's not proc still I'm losing my [__]
there you are
foreign
[Music]
sometimes I
I it really [__] sucks
then there's that one attack that I
don't like
where I have to be a certain distance
away or it's guaranteed to hit me
God
we're taking a risk
I have to be a certain distance away or
that like he runs around and then does a
long sweep that you can't Dodge if
you're too close
when it with a boss that requires you to
be in his dick
I want to cry like it it's like the game
the gay great a rune Arc and wanted to
kill me he's his [__] Christ
how many times have I done that right
there how many [__] times have I
have I done the dragon move there and
this it just randomly hits me sometimes
I just get hit
I'm losing my mind if you couldn't tell
I'm I'm actually [__] losing my mind
thank you
oh my God pulled that one out didn't you
radon
I got lucky
foreign
I don't get it
I don't I don't even have enough time to
drink a blue potion in between combos
this is insane
don't I don't even have enough time to
drink a blue potion in between combos
that is unbelievable that's like the
fastest thing you can do
oh
I'm so tired of this animation too like
I'm mad at everything right now
I'm so tired of this bull that's
probably why my eyes aren't working this
blinding ass light every time I run in
here
sure I'm in your horse but you can hit
me with your sword sure
foreign
I do not have much more in me guys
I'm too old for this [__]
this is this feels harder than Melania
on the original rumorlette this
legitimately feels harder than that
foreign
the balls are just whiffing they're just
sliding off of them
why
I swear that God the balls get move on
them sometimes and you can't do anything
they just slide everywhere
[Music]
this [__] boss man holy [__]
is this doing this early I guess
foreign
this is insane
holy [__]
oh
that was a great depiction of how fast
he is
I'm Not Gonna Get You poisoned am I
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
that hitbox can be Wicked right there by
the way
[Music]
why don't I take that risk there
she is not being kind
[Music]
foreign
thank you
I walked away for a minute
I went pee I got another drink
all the things
hopefully this looks as hard as it is
did I not have stamina
I hit the roll button the game ate my
input cool
like I'm playing only up
this does the randomizer make Redan the
how he originally was
is that something
like is this is this 1.0 radon
this don't feel like normal radon
I've beaten radon hundreds of times
without dying
this is [__] ridiculous
I've beaten him hundreds of times
without dying it's it's like actually
causing me to to go nuts right now
I have less Health in the in the speed
run
and
this is wicked I feel like I'm gonna go
to a regular game like game and Rodan
will be a joke at this point
foreign
I think I'm still in the animation there
if he does any other attack I can live I
just shouldn't do that there
look at him riding around
yeah if you guys don't know how radon
was before he got patched he was
actually crazy
let me just take a moment to look at
this character's stats
have you seen a worse
allocation of points
I mean
Jesus Christ
thank you wheel
yeah it's the Elon Musk build yeah
uh unfortunately he cannot fall
there's a giant invisible wall like even
you can't fall
I don't know what I'm doing
this build is terrible
I cannot preface how bad this this build
is
it is bad I don't have any light it's
getting [__] dark chat that's how
long we've been here it's getting dark
and I'm losing my natural light from the
window
pretty soon you won't be able to see me
and I'm not gonna change the lighting
I refuse to put that [__] ring light
into my eyes anymore it burns my retinas
I'll probably turn on that light
and I have a light right here
a good start you [__] [__]
oh no
there it is
he did every attack I didn't want and I
got impatient
light some candles I should get some
candles
good
foreign
he's doubled up right I don't want to
look at the health bar
I wanted to make him bleed
I wanted to make him bleed my own blood
thank you
foreign
[__] hell dude
[Music]
just die
such an annoying last boss man
foreign
that attack is Brutal by the way
it's an insta kill if either sweep hits
me
so is that
I'm pretty sure if any attack hits me I
die
[Music]
and her second face is way worse
foreign
holy [__] gamer mode activated
[Music]
so annoying man
let's do I I forgot what segment the
delay was at
oh
[Music]
I thought the delay was later
rockers
I thought the delay was later man
no we've barely gotten any tears in the
randomizer Jay we have like three well
we got some magic ones but they're
worthless
feel like I need something for her
is Loretta resistant to to Holy
it's
a gun
right
no
this weapon could be quite good
against trigger
we'll switch to that
holy [__] I'm gonna I thought I had it
there boys
I really did I just forgot what part of
that [__] blue attack was delayed in
it
I wasn't ready whatever
was flipping through [__]
yeah we tried lightning and it was trash
so
at least the lightning that we got
I really did
think I had it there
I'm burning this entire world to the
goddamn ground
blame a frenzy Style baby
I'll see if I can get all this footage
because we can do it if metal wants to
edit this into a video she can
I'm just smacking Leonard in the face
dude what are these
have you guys ever seen that attack
before
I don't think I have
I'm done
[Music]
attack
he's given me nothing for the rut
[Music]
this is really early for him to do this
whatever
[Music]
yeah his build up resistance is very
high
yeah we got to
we got to Loretta
she's very hard
okay
did I wait to proc him
until he starts doing the phase two
stuff
like should I just hit him until he does
like the overhead swing
and then ProCom
it might be better
let me try that
good night grim
all right
[Music]
what the [__] is that
such a weird
animation does he normally do that like
the like kind of a backhand turn like
that I don't know if I've ever seen that
it just looks so awkward in game
oh
we are living on the edge
foreign
[Music]
what the [__] was that
the only thing that happened there was
that I got frustrated that my balls went
through him and did no damage so I just
doubled it up and that means I die
yeah you can Poise break with breath
attacks uh by the way that's good to
know
learn something new in this game every
[__] day
every time I play it
foreign
[Music]
you have to wait for that
is that consistent I can't get to the
head can I nope
man
he's proc though
just just let me drink a blue man like
why not you just did a giant overhead
attack but I guess not
foreign
attack I'm like that's time to drink a
blue no it's not right into the next
combo
oh man
like we got a new Strat
we can please break him with the Scarlet
rot
and beforehand I guess
no he's gonna aim it at me David
foreign
[Applause]
that sucks I couldn't get poison off
[Music]
it just didn't hit and I just didn't
think he'd do that that's okay
like why do the balls just suddenly not
have a hitbox at random times it's so
frustrating
like I'm on his leg and it just goes
right through
whatever game from soft does after armor
core 6 they really need to chill with
the hyper aggression these Elden ring
bosses have
I mean
I feel like they designed the game to be
played once I've said that for a long
time they didn't even design the game to
be played for a long time
they wanted you to play it once for like
150 hours
and then we'd never notice all these
[__] weird things about the bosses
right through them
couldn't even heal once
there we go
foreign
that's not good folks
he just didn't do the slam
why the world may never know
his AI decided not to
why am I not
just got eaten
hey Ty thank you for the tarnish
membership man I appreciate that thank
you
um man
they didn't know we play 150 different
worlds killing every boss with a
different unique way each time and I
guess not I don't know it doesn't
I don't know
I mean Plus
I guess so
I guess they just don't care
it's another Factor
cool
I decided to do a jump attack and that
means I die awesome
I kind of agree I don't really like New
Game Plus either
I don't do it very often
I don't think I I did it once with my
first character and that's it
some people like it though
these bosses aren't going to age well in
the next five years
um well they will
I still think Elden ring is the best
game ever made
um and you only notice these issues
after 1400 hours like me
thank you
why did I miss
um is he not running around like a lot
more than usual there
foreign
did not stagger him that time folks
what is this [__]
this time we've seen that in three hours
I really want to poison him before he
jumps
[Music]
I think I did
um you guys think I poisoned him or not
[Music]
foreign
we gotta hit him
okay he's gonna throw the rocks
my balls have just faded through him on
three attacks in a row
it's not good
he was so [__] hyper aggressive there
holy [__]
did that
foreign
I'm gonna wait for that moment again
oh it didn't work
she's not in it man
do it again
you're such a good boss
okay she stinked
foreign
[Music]
I don't think I have any opportunity to
use rot right she's too fast
[Music]
all right holy sword good call
Voice break yeah
[Music]
I'm close to some sort of wall I feel it
is that too slow
how much damage did I do
it's hard to tell actually right now
that does a lot
[Music]
that goes everywhere
do I have to roll still can I just run
foreign
[Music]
I think I can just run right I I got
I got [__] scared because she's
shooting four of them at once now
okay well we have at least a better
Strat there I guess I don't [__] know
God dude why did it have to be Loretta
she's such a [__] annoying boss with
no Health dude she's the worst
God
he was terrible in the Rune roulette way
back then
it's terrible now
thank you
bro
I cannot preface how [__] hard this
is I'm like level 10.
116.
you know they're all spread out all over
the [__] place
why did that [__] hit me why I've
been there a million times doing the
exact same thing
and it just hits
[__] you
bleed two [__]
[Music]
hey
I just should not have relied on the
poison man
the hardest attack that he has to dodge
you have to dodge
perfectly in or you if you get hit by
one you get staggered and then you hit
by the rest
I I just got scared that was a weird
sequence
like I just threw the poison out and he
just didn't stand in it
whatever
all right
[__] you [__] you [__] you
foreign
didn't take so God damn long
man dude
it just takes forever
to do it
I was going really really good though
I think I should if I if I knock him
down again that's when I'm gonna rot him
that's gotta be better I I get to like
oh I gotta go repost his face when I
really [__] don't
that triggers me so much that it just
randomly hits me sometimes too
couldn't have been better
[Music]
why are you not jumping thank you
got the Strat we have the strap
it wouldn't be a from software game if
you could cancel animations
you have to commit to the input
thank you
commit to the input
oh my God let me get out of the
animation for the love of God
yeah there's some animations I just mean
like the main ones
it would be nice to cancel this Dragon
animation
you know like this
or this
you know what caused me to die there
I had the switch
from the poison to the rot and that took
too long
so I died
pressing up on the d-pad once took too
long here
I have two Talisman slots Robert
that's all we found
very aggressive
quite literally I've never seen that
before
Loretto YouTube we've been there a few
times it's really [__] hard because
she has an insane amount of health and
there's barely any points to hit her and
you die in one hit
as with radon
shouldn't have reached you I mean he
spreads it all over the [__] Arena so
it was just a bad luck
it was bad luck that he decided to do
that attack in that moment he does
anything else I can dodge it but he did
that one
sometimes he gets like squirrely you
guys see it like that looked that
animation looked different from how it
normally looks like he looks squirrely
like the
like the arena is kind of distorting his
body a little bit to just make it look
different
yes read the pinned comment Souls
I've had to spin a wheel for all my
levels and it's [__] trash
I drank a blue flask and I die
I don't see the comment read the top of
the chat the blue thing with my name in
it
you don't see it
in the in the chat room
if you can't see it then I firmly
believe that YouTube's like AI or UI is
just completely [__] random for
everybody
like right now I don't have the
membership button it's just not there
but sometimes it is
I'm having a good time
laughs
oh I got you yeah
yeah it's at the top of the chat
I don't want to do this anymore
can I say that I like don't want to do
it anymore I don't I'm not having fun at
all this sucks
that's not what I meant YouTube account
I just can't see the button it's not
like I would become a member of my own
channel
I'm just sometimes I see the buttons
sometimes I don't
because I was talking about UI
what the [__] do I do about that random
ass [__] what the hell
I'm like inside of the horse and I'm
still getting hit by that
holy [__] I don't want to do this
anymore oh my god oh
this is torture
I wanted to go and hit golf balls four
hours ago and I'm still here
it's getting dark
I told myself this stream will take
three and a half hours that was my goal
I'm on eight
oh
[Music]
they have lights not at all of them holy
[__] chat
oh I'm one-handed right now I'm losing
my mind
try another Weapon It's a randomizer I
don't even have upgrades for other
weapons like shut up
I'm doing with what I got here
I'm sorry I'm losing my patience dude oh
my God
this isn't even Rune level one like
there's cases in room level one where
you can get hit and not die
you got some [__] for that I don't know
but
this this is just ridiculous like this
allocation of points is just trash for
everything that we want to do
it's just bad
this is like Rune level one is like you
get what you get this is just
a bad build
through
LOL it's okay man don't say low to me
ever again I'm mad at you now
foreign
people start that [__] with a little oh
my God
[Music]
I just wouldn't test me right now guys
I wouldn't do it
um
I just wouldn't do it
I have the ax Talisman and something
else I promise the talismans are not
making a difference here
foreign
I die in one [__] hit
so thank you
oh
I didn't even know that's what was
happening in that attack till just now
I thought he had to do the big load up
run around cross his arms jump in the
air to do that attack but nope he has
another variation of it
there it is
guys
I would not recommend back seating me
right now bro
I wouldn't do it
there is no Talisman that is going to
stop us from being from dying in one hit
okay it's just not gonna happen
[__] you can't back seat and say I'm not
backseat
thank you
why are you testing me right now man
why are you doing it
damn it dude it's so hard to see
do not argue with me right now bro I am
not in the mood I don't want to hear it
dude I [__] hate it when people talk
like that I legit asked if you had
something I didn't say do this shut the
[__] up
[__] you [__] get out of my stream [__]
you you [__] loser
goodbye there it was I triggered him a
little bit chat oh your stream sucks and
you suck there it was little [__]
worm get the hell out of here
I knew it was coming I could feel it in
his first comment man
God I [__] hate people like that
doing this so long I can feel it before
it even happens
little
[__] Anonymous inbred loser
just read the pin comment Felipe
okay
dude I could just feel it on that guy
right before I banned him I'm like this
guy's gonna say something dumb as soon
as he started saying like bro I didn't
even mean it like that even though
you're doing the thing you don't mean to
do
just because you say you're not doing
something doesn't mean you're not doing
it
foreign
yeah I'm not back seating but
let me backseat here real quick
and all I said was please don't backseat
bro I'm not I just said I wasn't
bruh
please stop you know what this [__]
stream is trash and you're [__]
terrible oh well there we go there it is
saw it coming
[Music]
foreign
how many of my attacks just went through
them
too many
why does he get up so fast
nope he didn't do it again oh wait it's
here it's here
all right
okay that was good
[Music]
he's gonna start off big
ah
it's just it's slightly too slow guys
sometimes she does a three combo there
the attack is just too [__] slow
it's just too slow
every attack is too slow
it does good damage though but so does
this
oh man
[__] bro
these both of these bosses are
ridiculously fast
not a fan of people who flip on you on a
dime whenever you challenge them in any
way
it's what it's what people on the
internet do
like these are not like these Anonymous
people on the internet man I'm telling
you
how about you get on a camera
on stream in front of however many
people and do it yourself
[Music]
come on [__]
half my attacks are going through him
oh
he's still not Proctor man
there it is now he is
it's literally getting dark outside
I don't want to do this anymore guys I'm
sorry I'm literally not having fun at
all dude
this is just awful
this is way harder than roon roulette
Melania by the way this is way [__]
harder
I don't think it'll take me as long but
because I've gotten a lot better at the
game but this is in [__] sane
foreign
[Music]
that kind of blows I didn't even get a
chance to use poison
might just deal with it
foreign
oh my gosh she is so goddamn fast bro
[Music]
foreign
I'll take the horse kick into the face
sure
[Music]
if I stay close to her is she more prone
to do these attacks
dude I can't Dodge those
or just by running that's awful
I want a poison her so bad
what is that [__]
this could not be a more annoying boss
foreign
got you that time [__]
oh that's a quick variation
yes let's go
I can gravel Stone
[Music]
finally
and it gave me the most worthless item
in the game
oh Anna Sombra nine
dude burn down
we have to do our final spins
just to see the end of the build
right
just to see the end of it
there's four Zapdos thank you for the
great room membership man
I'm sorry for getting so [__] mad
chat holy [__] I hated every second of
that it changed much but you deserve
this thank you Angel for the Super Chat
I appreciate it man thank you
thank you oh man I'm sorry I get so
irritated some some little comments
irritate the [__] out of me but what
I've been sitting here for eight hours
trying to [__] get this [__] done and
people start little these little test
comments
um I cannot hold myself back from being
a dick bro I will be a dick
to people who are annoying me in the
worst times man okay at least it's over
final spins we get four more spins
if it gives me four slots of vigor okay
there we go
in endurance
they deserved it uh maybe
I don't really care if they do or don't
mind
yo John thank you as well man I
appreciate it
thank you dude
strength
uh
guys that sucked dick in it l
ol all right guys Here's the final build
Here's the final build
here I'll turn off my thing here
21 vigor
31 mind
21 endurance
23 strength
31 decks
16 intelligence
1e9 faith
and 27 arcane
what an absolute abomination of a build
level 120.
what an absolute train wreck of a build
imagine if someone did this
I can't
burn it all
burn it all down
burn it all down baby
that's all I want to see
for it all to light on fire
congrats my guy you are one resilient
dude I appreciate the five dollar Super
Chat tight thank you man
I think I do have a bit of resilience
and maybe a little bit of insanity
Within Me Maybe I'm a little crazy
uh when it comes to beating my head
against a wall to finish these
challenges sometimes
you know maybe I should have just gone
tomorrow uh
it's not what the title said
yeah
yeah burn away all the suffering and
pain
distinguish all that divides and hurts
May chaos take the world
chaos you let I lived in a world of
chaos for the last four hours my guy
this is nothing to me
this is how I've felt bird all day
fire
burn it all down
yes
uh-huh
um
absolutely
GG
I can't wait for mommy to hunt me down
and deliver me what I deserve
I cannot wait for mommy to hunt me down
bro
come find me I dare you
I dare you to hunt me down
oh I want you to
I do deserve it I want it I deserve it
and want it
I will seek you as far as you may travel
you're goddamn right you will
to deliver you but is yours
destined death please do
she would [__] you up I hope so
that's gotta be the major hint to the
DLC right there right
GG folks
[Music]
um that went five and a half five hours
ten minutes longer than I wanted it to
but we did it
we did it
thanks for hanging out with me
thanks for enduring the pain as I did
I appreciate y'all
um by the way I'm going to be
exclusively not exclusively I'm just
gonna say I'm likely going to be
streaming on Kik from now on guys
it's a it's a new streaming platform
that we're trying out
um all the vods will always go on to the
live channel the VOD Channel
from those if we do Elden ring
challenges but I'm gonna be streaming
there from now on so if you haven't
followed yet it's in the description we
we're gonna do some more challenges like
this
that are hopefully not as hard Maybe
they probably will be
anyway
go follow if you want to I'm out of here
thanks again for hanging out
I'll be on tomorrow doing something
so
have a good rest of your day folks
peace and love
and I'll see you all again soon
bye bye